Donald Trump speaking an interview said
that he worries about World War III
because of what's going on with Taiwan
and Ukraine and Mr President you may be
correct because right now we got a huge
story this did come out yesterday and
some people were talking about but more
developments have come in
to explosions registered near the
nordstream pipelines these run natural
gas from Russia and to Germany and two
explosions are registered now there's a
kilometer wide gas leak in the Baltic if
a ship goes over it like sinks but
that's not the point the point is
right now there's accusations of
sabotage because of the explosions and
the question is who did it of course the
West Ukraine in particular they're
blaming Russia saying was an act of
Terror but then many people are pointing
out that Joe Biden said in February with
a smile on his face if Russia invades
Ukraine there will be no nordstream
pipeline the reporter seemingly not
understanding what Joe Biden was saying
says how can you control it Germany
controls it and then he says I promise
you there will be no pipeline so when
there's an explosion detected by
researchers and then a major leak you
have to wonder who did it and why
there's good reason to believe that
Russia would stage a false flag they
need the morale boost they need to say
we are being attacked this is our way of
making money but at the same time I
don't think the simple solution is
Russia attacks themselves at a time when
they need all the resources they can get
and it's a major bargaining chip for
them hey you back off and stop funding
Ukraine we turn the gas back on all of a
sudden now the bargaining chip gone
so Donald Trump may be right world war
three at the same time there are
questions about what's happening inside
our own country a viral video showing a
hundred people young people storming
into a Wawa in Philadelphia one woman
jumps up on a counter starts twerking as
they just destroy everything so whether
it's Fallen apart around the world or
here uh things are getting pretty crazy
so we're going to talk about all of that
plus a bunch of other stories before we
get started my friends head over to
timcast.com become a member by clicking
that join us button to support our work
and the work of our journalists they're
putting out stories every single day
fact checking you will also get access
to the uncensored members only show
we'll have one of the one of those up
for you at 11 PM we have a huge library
of guests you know big names and other
people you'd love to watch and we swear
a lot not very family friendly so you
don't want to miss it it's a good show
that'll be up tonight at 11. don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends you can follow us at
timcastirl be the notification a lot of
people are pointing out YouTube's not
notifying people the stream's going up
likely right before the midterms not a
coincidence you guys want to support our
work and fight back against censorship
be that notification share that show
joining us today to talk about all of
this is don't walk run hello hello
everybody thank you Tim who are you oh
hey uh so I'm Andrew uh the top senior
political analyst on YouTube uh don't
walk run Productions that's my channel
and uh yeah glad to be here thanks for
having me back right on we also have the
T-shirt Merchant himself that's right
hey guys this is lukerdowski here of we
are change.org looking good I don't know
who you're voting for in 2024 but I'm
voting in Brandon and if you agree with
that message you could get the shirt the
lovely shirt that I'm wearing right now
on the
bestpoliticalshirts.com they're very
good quality they stretch very well if
you have any problems with the shirts
email us right away we'll send you a new
one the best politicalshirts.com because
you guys buy shirts this is why I'm here
thanks so much for having me you look
good thank you I think it's the glasses
yeah yeah I appreciate it thank you man
I've been working out yeah I've been
doing a lot of work it is kind of weird
too that like this room is extremely
gray and then it cuts to Ian he's
wearing this beautiful what's up you're
distracting everyone Ian why are you
distracting everybody I'm a polar bear
and that's not what you think it means
uh hi everyone Ian Crossland here
um unfortunately there is a large
tropical storm in the Southeast and my
meditations did not disperse the clouds
I've only ever done that locally
but uh prayers to the people that are
experiencing the winds I know a lot of
people down there let's let's move this
along and get to talking about it yeah
for sure hopefully everyone in Florida
is fine we had somebody up here to help
us with our Rumble to keep it running
smoothly over at timcast.com so much
appreciation to the rumble peeps for
keeping us online during Hurricane Ian
all Ian's fault just saying all right
let's get going well no so real quick
just to address that uh Rumble operates
out of Florida and so there's a bunch of
data centers there we use rumble's
infrastructure for timcast.com and uh so
there could be some interruptions but
Rumble sent an elite special agent to
make sure that everything was operating
really really well because they're
awesome so we are grateful and I hope
everybody in Florida is taking it
seriously it might drop down to a
category two the hurricaneian so that's
good news it's still really dangerous
and high-speed wins they're saying like
a 10-foot storm surge so there's going
to be a lot of flooding take it
seriously man Tampa and I think uh um
the last I saw DeSantis said two million
people under evacuation orders something
like that I think so don't mess around
with this stuff uh take it seriously
live uh Live Another Day a lot of people
think they'll be fine but um
you you just gotta you take care of
yourself man uh we're seeing empty store
shelves people are fleeing and it's
probably a good idea to get out of the
way if you can so let's jump into this
first story maybe we'll talk about the
hurricane in a bit from tempgas.com two
explosions registered near nordstream
pipelines causing gas to leak in Baltic
Sea a senior Ukrainian official accused
Russia of the explosions calling them an
act of terrorism now you may have
noticed we titled this show us accused
and that's because online what you're
seeing pop up all over Twitter and on
social media is a video of Joe Biden
saying that the U.S was going to take
this action I think it's it's obvious
that Russia is being accused of doing
this but my issue right there is we
could we get tight we could structure
the story and frame it a certain way we
can say U.S accused which we chose to do
we could say Russia accused which I feel
kind of makes no sense or we could say
both U.S and Russia separately accused
of of state of engaging in sabotage the
issue I take with this is that if Russia
were to have been the one that detonated
explosion that detonated some device
blowing up the pipeline it's a false
flag attack and I don't think that's the
simple solution I think it's more likely
that we have this story right here check
this out this is from February 8th if
Russia invades Ukraine there will be no
nordstream 2 Biden says I mean he just
outright he says it and then he smirks
when he's asked by a reporter well how
would you do anything about it you have
no control and he says I promise you
there will be no nordstring pipeline
then we learn about an operation ball
tops 22 a U.S Navy uh Navy's sixth fleet
was doing exercises with mind detection
and mock explosives near born home
Denmark which is where the explosions
happened now no matter how you cut it we
got a conspiracy who did it why did they
do it I don't think it actually matters
the U.S some people think they did it
because Biden said he was gonna he's
basically said there would be no
pipeline but Russia they could they
could stage a false flag to try and
boost morale because they're
conscripting people and they need people
willing and happy to fight so which is
it I think you made a good point that
it's one of the more valuable assets to
destroy that wouldn't make a lot of
sense like Pearl Harbor whether or not
you think it was a false flag some
people think it was in the case that
they didn't know they were going to get
attacked in Pearl Harbor but they let it
happen anyway they didn't know exactly
where or when but they had five aircraft
carriers out of port or a bunch of four
of their five aircraft or some if the
aircraft carriers had been at Pearl
Harbor and they had been sunk Japan
would have invaded San Francisco next so
the US was ready for Pearl Harbor
whether or not it seemed like it in
eventually Hawaii is decently far away
but I don't know about San Francisco
well if we didn't have the aircraft
carriers to defend the Japanese would
have controlled the Pacific after that
battle so also with any event you got to
ask yourself who really benefits here
but even Beyond going the speculation
here I think a lot of the other comments
made by other prominent politicians
absolutely matter here the Danish Prime
Minister said that it's quote hard to
imagine that this is accidental the
Polish prime minister said that this was
an act of sabotage and now the former
Ministry of defense for Poland sent out
a message on Twitter saying thank you
USA with a picture of of course the the
pipeline that of course busted off of
Denmark so there's a lot of crazy stuff
happening Ukraine is blaming Russia
Russia is blaming the West who's
responsible here we do not know but this
is going to guarantee a dark winter in
Europe Europe is already in a major
energy crisis this guarantees very
severe problems ahead of us that are
going to be very impactful for the
average people for the poorest people in
Europe that are going to be devastated
by this who who is this guy it's radek
Circus Circus Sikorsky sorry and I
believe uh he's a member of European
Parliament chairman EU USA delegation
uh I'm not sure exactly I I heard he's
from Poland you know who he is I think
he's the former Ministry of defense is
that yeah I don't know this guy right
here Reddick Sikorski says thank you USA
he's verified on Twitter as a member of
European Parliament
um yeah the USA is probably the one that
did it or whoever's it's just like
there's no way I I seriously doubt
Russia you might stage a false flag to
get people to go to war but when you're
already in war it's pretty I mean it's
not off the impossible that you would
say it's a false flag to get people to
go do something within the war but also
specifically there is blow up your own
frequency there was forewarning that
this was going to happen according to
Reuters the CIA was warning Berlin about
the possibility on attacks on these
pipelines the summer of this year so the
CIA knew this was happening there was
war games this Tim was talking about I I
think again you got to ask yourself who
does this benefit this stops the
possibility of another bargaining chips
this stops the possibility of
negotiations this stops the possibility
of Europe having energy this stops the
possibility of what a lot of people are
calling the great reset that of course
is being only going to be pushed forward
by this latest action this is the crazy
thing right we've got Russia invading
Ukraine which means fertilizer shortages
food shortages so naturally what do the
nether what does the Netherlands do they
instruct their Farmers to stop farming
well that makes a whole lot of sense
doesn't it Netherlands I believe is the
second biggest exporter of food in it
could be it could be in the world I
might be wrong about that and they're
being the farmers are being told to stop
farming over climate change now you've
got the nordstream pipeline was already
shut down there's two there's Nordstrom
one and two they were not delivering
Russia shut down deliveries in beginning
of September and said indefinitely
why would Russia blow up a pipeline
they've already cut off access to
I suppose you make the argument they
want to be like hey look we're being
attacked quick everybody come fight on
our on our behalf the U.S bragged about
it but more importantly to get look no
matter which way you cut it there's a
conspiracy here either it was the U.S it
was Russia it was who knows right
but there's also the dark winter as Luke
mentioned this guarantees there will be
no negotiating with Russia to reopen
Europe will not be able to be pressured
into succumbing to the whims of Russia
think about this way winter comes
pipeline is shut off
Germany says to Russia we will do
anything we are freezing we need the
energy and Russia says stop the support
for Ukraine and they say anything you
say turns the switch gas flows back into
Europe let's say the CIA or whoever who
knows the U.S blows up the pipeline or
damage it damages it to such a degree it
will not be able to provide resources
they can't up the pressure they can't
set the flow it'll leak out in the
Baltic now Germany will not be able to
go to Russia and beg because Russia has
nothing to offer the only outcome now is
they have to keep supporting the war
there's other pipelines too going from
Russia into Europe some of them also or
go from Russia to Turkey but it's also
important to note here that a lot of the
other pipelines go through Ukraine so
it's it's in a battlefield right now
there's a lot of things at stake here
Timothy what are you doing here he's got
ideas is what he's what he's talking
about and I wasn't saying anything go
back to Luke anyway Andrew what do you
think who do you think's responsible
here geopolitically how do you think
this is going to play out from here
is there something different about you
the glasses I'm telling you it's the
glasses
I just cannot put my finger on it might
be a new shirt I am I'm uh I'm just
hypnotized
I don't know I have hair looks a little
lighter well so so and look guys I know
I know you all think Luke is handsome
and beautiful but thank you but Andrew
what are your thoughts on this I mean
we've been kind of going off what do you
think I've just been listening it's very
it's very informative uh I like all your
takes uh and well look
I we don't know how extensive the damage
is we don't know
uh
I mean I I do agree that with Russia uh
needing needing troops that if if they
did do this or if they didn't do this
they have Joe Biden basically saying I'm
gonna do it so so right right February
right well he said there will be no
Nordstrom too right they didn't like
this is a leak you're right we don't
know the extent of the damage right we
don't know how how quickly can be fixed
yes right but the spread is a kilometer
what the the so we have this picture
right of the of the leak that's a
kilometer is it leaking gas yes those
are bubbles so here's the here's a cool
thing a science lesson for all you for
all you nerds uh when there is a release
of gas rapidly it breaks apart surface
tension basically there's no uh buoyancy
because the water is being pushed apart
if a ship goes over it it will just drop
straight down like a hole is it like
like air gas you said they shut up and
shut it off oh so there was like
residual methane they're still in it and
the pressure drops like it's still it's
still pressure now it's all leaking yeah
fixing that thing sounds like an utter
nightmare we're dealing with tremendous
pressure down below I actually did a
poll on my YouTube channel asking people
who do you think is really responsible
for this explosion on the Nordstrom
pipeline 71 percent of of people out of
ten thousand voters voted and said that
the United States did it twelve percent
said Russia did it five percent said it
was a legit accident accident and 12
percent said other foreign countries did
it so uh obviously a lot of people are
thinking that it was not Russia who did
this to themselves well maybe it was
climate change
things the water temperature changed so
fast that it caused a rapid expansion
and contraction of the pipe causing it
to bend and bursts and if those damn
Republicans would have voted for climate
change funding this would have never
happened did you see that video of the
woman in her car and she's like I just
paid 94 for gas 94.
I have to choose between food I guess
and then like she's ranting and I'm I'm
for a while I'm going like I'm with you
like I'm upset about this and then she
goes the religious right did this and
then I was just like well hold on there
a minute say what I don't understand how
you go from my guess is too expensive to
Christian's bed I just I don't I'm like
the religious right they're the ones
saying drill baby drill you know what I
mean you guys think if we seeded this
land of Russia this eastern Ukraine and
the freeways and stuff that they would
stop invading or is it like a Neville
Chamberlain thing where they gave Hitler
a little bit of a suddenlinity no they
uh I I've been saying this for a long
time I think that and at this point it's
probably way too late to negotiate
properly but uh the dunbars like you
know eastern Ukraine they they should
have just said it was it was basically
under Russian control anyway
so they might as well just said just
just take it just take it and that's it
and and they probably would have and
then we won't go to Nato but there was a
peace deal earlier this year where the
Russians said we won't take any of your
land you just don't sign up to Nato you
don't join the European Union and the
ukrainians and the Russians were were
agreeing to this and then Boris Johnson
flew to Ukraine and said no you don't
agree to the peace deal here and and
then there would have been no succeeding
to any land Russia wouldn't have taken
any additional land and there would have
been the truth but but of course Western
Powers pushed against that because give
them money like how how much are we in
the hole now 100 what's 60 billions 68
billion
I gotta make a point Ian you said uh is
it gonna be like Hitler and the Sudan
land you're saying right yeah like if we
see this land to Russia they'll keep
expanding yeah that's what they thought
of the two factions Russia and NATO
which one's been expanding in Europe
exactly NATO exactly so right now the
issue is not the like you comparing uh
Putin to Hitler is just a political well
Putin also took uh Crimea and there was
also a lot of tensions and land grabs in
Georgia so so there are some arguments
that you could you could make there
again I'm not a fan of any government we
need to see these issues from both sides
as from the arguments that are being
made here in order to try to push for a
bigger resolution here because all we're
seeing is escalation escalation
escalation and the bargaining chip today
was taken off the table that was a major
one that could have resolved a lot of
these problems that could have ended the
war that could have brought people cheap
energy and would have helped people
prosper during these very difficult
times which are being deliberately
engineered according to my own personal
opinion in order to push a larger agenda
of suffering on the rest of the
population translation you're saying
that the United States did it no I'm
saying here's what could be even beyond
that it could be a clandestine
organization outside of the United
States that has an invested interest a
rogue Nation it could be a corporation
intelligence agency Tom Cruise it could
be a rogue intelligence agency that
could have an invested interest in
saying hey we could sell a lot of
weapons here hey we could profit off of
the great reset hey we could we could
make a lot of money off of freezing
Europe and easily make it look like it
was the us because Biden says stupid
things on TV yeah we're living in a
world where multinational corporations
have a lot more power than governments
and we have to understand this reality
especially when it comes to shaping
world events staging them and of course
manipulating them in our current Society
let's let's pull this next story because
here's here's what's being reported in
the Press Daily Mail says did Putin's
frog men blow up Europe's gas supplies
Western leaders blame deliberate
sabotage after Nord stream pipe from
Russia ruptured off Sweden causing three
thousand foot wide Bubbles and sending
prices spiking three leaks were reported
in Nordstrom one and two near the Danish
Islands last night pipelines are leaking
gas from the Baltic so we covered a lot
of this the question is was it Moscow
they're claiming that it was his frog
men but what they don't ever put in
these stories is why would Russia blow
up their own means of selling gas into
Europe I don't understand but also it
makes no sense how much explosives would
you need like how much how much do you
do these frog men not carry really it's
only a few inches of concrete still
reinforced concrete and then I think
it's a 1.6 inch steel so theoretically a
very small device could get the job done
okay yep so here's my question prices
are spiking you know there's a group of
people that have been advocating for for
the the stoppage of fossil fuels for a
long time and these are Western
organizations so I just think it's very
strange that Joe Biden's whole agenda is
around he says we're gonna end fossil
fuels he shuts down uh he shuts down us
I promise you
there's gonna be no Nordstrom Pipeline
and I'm kind of like could there be an
element of the great reset
because this is the point I'm trying to
make why would the Netherlands tell
their Farmers to stop making food when
the the world was it the World Health
Organization is estimating hundreds of
millions will starve to death because of
the war in Ukraine and because of covid
now is the time to tell the farmers in
Netherlands you need to make more food
now is the time to be doing everything
possible to avoid nuclear war and to get
energy into Europe when the prices are
spiking I mean Germany is seeing
inflation at like 45 percent the
Sterling and the and the Euro have
dropped to Dollar parity but when you
see those things happen I can't help but
say they're stopping the use of fossil
fuels
they're telling Farmers stop farming and
now the economic crisis has brought
parity to the dollar the pound and the
Euro that's a that's that's the great
reset wet dream that Klaus Schwab is
probably you know let's just say he's
he's enjoying himself to put it mildly
yeah energy is being limited it's
becoming a artificially a scarcity
because it will bring up economic
upheaval that of course the central
Bankers are awaiting as an excuse to
bring in their Central Banking digital
currencies which of course the the many
central banks many federal reserves have
announced today that they're of course
pushing for that they're of course that
they want that of course is going to
create also why isn't anyone taking me
seriously why is everyone smiling when
I'm talking
it's hard to take Luke seriously when he
looks like Mrs Doubtfire why would they
say that I don't know Robin Williams
anyway whoa
you're I think is is deliberate I think
it's going to mean a lot of trouble for
a lot of individuals a lot of suffering
stop laughing Andrew
eyes up here oh my God and and and and
and how this is going to play out is
really not going to be in anyone's
benefit I think you made a really good
point that it could be corporations dude
multinational corporations unaccountable
corporations and and and you know things
out of the military-industrial complex
that that are private entities that
could get away with things that
government agencies can't so I've been
thinking if there is a global Revolution
man it's going to be against corporate
corporate but technocracy
huh what Sledge we're playing we're
playing charades Sledgehammer
technocracy yeah International corporate
technocracy is like my my main fear I'm
not worried about the Russians I'm not
worried about the Chinese I'm worried
about and of course I'm worried about
governments colluding with multinational
corporations but
you know I don't want technological
slavery foist on the people without them
realizing it let's pull up this map here
because this is what's going on here in
in over in Europe Russia's got a bunch
of pipelines going into Europe and they
basically control the flow of natural
gas gas problem has it all it's not just
Ukraine they've got uh two pipelines
going in looks like they have multiple
pipelines going into turkey they come up
it back into Europe they've got trans
gas there's yamal Europe there's the
northern lights and then Nordstrom is
bringing it into Germany several of
these pipelines are going into Germany
nordstream it looks like also connects
uh the BBL into the UK
there's a what I don't understand is
Russia
I guess destroying the pipeline stops
the flow of energy but Russia's trying
to sell this stuff into Europe so it I
don't know man uh what's what's the
outcome here is it world war three is it
is I mean Russia is going to blame the
U.S hands down how do you think this is
going to play out Andrew
well
I cover a lot of domestic stuff in my
channel so I'm really not the foreign
policy expert like Joe Biden is you know
I mean he's
he he knows what he's doing he you know
he's fine we he's we're gonna be
everything's gonna be fine because Joe
Biden is back America is back so I well
I saw these I'm sorry I'm just so
uh distracted
by dirt
your damn shirt Luke they're great
shirts they're they're great quality
they're amazing shirts they're amazing
so I was watching uh uh I was looking at
some of the photos coming out of Florida
we got hurricane Ian yes just ripping
through and already all the store
shelves are completely barren
people went in and they bought
everything up at the last minute
I look at that kind of stuff and I'm
like with what we're seeing now in
Europe I mean this is this is
they're saying sabotage people need to
understand how serious this is this is
this is a direct Act of War whoever did
this if it was some Rogue group okay if
in fact it wasn't an accident or or some
kind of uh flaw I think it was three
separate explosions is what I read
earlier but but were they in in two it's
completely separate areas or were they
from each other two areas like I'm
talking about area not not in in the
amount of time you know like there was
one in ten minutes there were a few
hours later I believe okay yeah all
right so what were they in the same
morning and then five in the morning but
were they in the same
vicinity no okay they're close to each
other enough to where you're getting one
big gas spread but okay so we don't know
but it's in the it's in an area where
the U.S Navy was conducting weird
operations I'm just saying outside of
that the reason I bring up the hurricane
stuff and the supply uh loss of supplies
is
I guess it all just comes back to we can
bring it bring it back to the domestic
policy stuff you know people in big
cities are going to be doomed if if this
really does escalate beyond what it just
what it is now and it's looking like it
Europe's screwed and all of these weird
woke European people no I mean we're
seeing Italy and we're seeing the right
start to win again but there's a lot of
woke craziness in Europe just like in
the United States what do you think is
going to happen to these people there's
no gas for winter they're they're not
going to have food they're not preparing
for this these people live the utmost
luxury like capital city and Hunger
Games and they have no idea what's in
store for them and I'll say the same for
people in the U.S when the hurricane
comes it's coming when the hurricane
started coming even Miami was getting
hit even though it's not in the direct
path like there's flooding there's a
video of a sewer lid popping off and
people are rushing to stores at the last
minute like oh no I don't know what to
buy these people have done no research
on what they need to do to survive their
skills are not suited for these kinds of
disasters and it seems like no matter
what there's just more and more disaster
happening around the planet you got
escalation of War what have happens when
it when when this results in major
economic collapse here in the U.S
because seeing what happens to the pound
and the Euro that's going to Ripple
across and hit us too when these
countries have no demand for U.S dollars
because there well actually maybe the
opposite will happen maybe the
destruction of the North Street pipeline
makes them desperate for oil and they
have no choice but to buy US dollars
from us but their currency is now
worthless we're basically going to own
Europe
yep and if if there ever was a way to
create a cashless Society this this this
would be it and as we know according to
the world economic Forum they want to
create a carbon social credit score and
and I think a lot of this plays into it
and I think the the financial Calamity
that we're seeing is deliberate I think
energy exploration production has been
deliberately brought down by a lot of
these policies to make the weather
better but in reality it's not making
the weather better it's actually causing
more pollution in many instances causing
a lot of suffering and again you limit
energy to the population you limit
prosperity of the population so there's
a correlation between both lack of
energy lack of prosperity for
individuals to actually do things in
life to actually buy things in life to
travel places to make and commence
Commerce all of that I think is being
directly targeted and I think we're
seeing the effects of that with the
poorest people in the world becoming a
lot poorer I think that's only going to
progress even further I think the people
in Europe are going to spend their
savings on heating their homes on trying
to keep their business this is open if
they can because a lot of the times many
of these businesses will have to shut
down because the operating costs the
taxes the regulations Just Simply Having
the heat on in your business will be too
expensive for the average person to be
even able to afford it no you go to jail
exactly well in uh yeah Switzerland is
is even advertising saying hey if if
your neighbor is heating their home past
66 degrees you better tell us because
you will face a major fine you can even
face jail time if you can't pay the fine
and you know we're daring to eat your
home you know we learned from covet
they'll do it you know their neighbors
will rat you out in Canada for during
World War One there's propaganda where
it's like do not hoard if you have more
than one bag of flour it's illegal and
they would come and arrest they'd look
for you and arrest you if you were
hoarding so I could have you know we
gotta watch out that they start don't
start hunting people down for hoarding
food
you know because people have been
stocking up well with a crisis that's
being engineered what's scarcity that's
being engineered you could get away with
emergency protocols emergency laws
emergency uh actions because whenever
you give government power during
emergencies eventually government will
start creating emergencies that's the
train of thinking that I come from
that's my own personal opinion and I
think we saw a lot what happened with
with kovid that is very alarming that
did show a lot of people that didn't see
an alternative point of view that didn't
question things that just accepted it
because it was the only thing that they
saw social media went along with that
they censored certain ideas they certain
they censored certain scientists they
censored individuals who were speaking
out some of them were even arrested some
of them were even debanked in places
like Canada for daring to speak out
against the current status quo against
the system that of course was telling
people that they couldn't even go
outside of their homes Australia you
couldn't even go down the street you
couldn't walk away from your house you
would end up in a a coveted Camp which
is absolutely crazy Let's uh let's bring
this uh back home with this story on
your post the prophet the great leader
himself did you know that Donald Trump
means Herald of the world ruler I don't
know yeah Donald Donald Irish or
something it's Scottish Donald means
World ruler or World wielder okay and
Trump means the the trumpet sound the so
it's it's translates to like the
announcement the the the the the the
beckoning or the you know the
announcement of the world ruler do you
know what Joe Biden means
what I I don't know anyway Donald Trump
warns of possible World War III Over
Ukraine and Taiwan and it's funny
because we look at the story and it's
like oh wow Donald Trump is warning over
and it's like you know everyone's kind
of been saying that already it was a bit
late to the party but I'm wondering
um I guess what I'm wondering with this
story is yes especially with what we're
seeing with the sabotage and this
pipeline in Europe and with China firing
missiles over Taiwan we've never been
closer uh we've never been closer to a
major International Conflict at least in
our lifetimes I mean obviously we had
War but I'm saying like right now and so
I wonder though
are people going to see this two
questions what will this what impact
will all of this have on the midterms
are people going to hear what Trump is
saying and be like yes Joe Biden is
causing more war or he's a terrible
leader and he can't handle it we need
someone stronger will this result in
Republican Victory or even a trump
victory in 2024 what do you think
well unfortunately a lot of Republicans
are are
very gung-ho in sending Ukraine more
money and more money and more money and
it just it doesn't end we're just it's
this money printer Gober how much do you
need Vladimir you know I mean it's it's
ridiculous so uh so you're not going to
have the Republicans
campaigning off of that but if everybody
knew how much that we're sending over
there to prolong a war that could have
ended months ago or in fact probably
wouldn't have even started if Donald
Trump had still been president and had a
second term right I don't know about
that Trump did send lethal weapons to
Ukraine and did something that Obama
wouldn't even dare to do so Obama was
too scared to send lethal weapons there
but do you think that Russia would have
it's hard it's very hard to say it's
hard to say but but I'll tell you what
it didn't it didn't happen when Trump
was President so we know that for a fact
well there's there's other escalations
especially in the dumbass region and the
Crimea region between Russia and the and
but not in the western not not to the
scale of course no no now it's tragic
now the life loss the the severity of
the situation is is very big so Trump
trump kind of had a very chaotic
bombastic foreign policy it was kind of
uh he even described himself as half
nationalistic half globalist he said
that himself and I think that was very
fairly represented with a lot of his
actions which some people cheered on and
some people were like what in the world
are you doing stop it like with Siri
or trying to start a war with Iran uh
again lots of ridiculousness that comes
there but but Tim you asked you know
will people listen to Donald Trump no
he's not on social media they can't
listen to him I heard Twitter's gonna
bring him back do you hear this uh
Facebook also said maybe they'll bring
them back they announced that they're
going to be looking at this he's truth
and but he's he's speaking to the echo
chamber he's speaking to his people that
are becoming isolated and people are
doubling down on of course hearing their
ideas regurgitated back to them rather
than of course having debates sparking
real conversations and actually engaging
the general public in conversations that
actually do matter and affect people and
are willing to challenge their beliefs
but what I what I mean is
do you think regular people are seeing
what's going on right now because of the
war escalation and being like Joe
Biden's not doing a good job well no
because no no Trump is saying what he's
saying but the Republicans they're not
they're not going to go there because
they're for the war I'm talking about
the people in Congress I I like
Republican leaderships like like Kevin
McCarthy uh is is for it but you know
you might have you know Josh Hawley but
he's not he's not leadership he's not
Republican leadership so I'd say for I'd
say the majority of the Republican party
right now they're they're talking about
domestic issues they're not they're
they're not they don't want to be like
oh well they're they're Russian you know
they're Russian uh uh sympathizers
because they want the war to stop in in
Ukraine uh but you just need to get I
think a lot of people I don't think that
the majority of Americans understand
that we shouldn't be there that were
there under false pretenses and that
we're spending way too much money wow
that sounds familiar
you could like that's that that
describes American foreign policy for
the past 40 years yeah uh but we're it's
not it's not something that's gonna
turned the tide for Republicans this
pipeline stuff and Taiwan stuff could
people are going to be like hey I think
there needs to be I think there needs to
be well Taiwan I mean that's a whole
different story and Joe Biden's saying
oh yeah we're gonna you know I've I've
never I don't think I've ever seen a
commander-in-chief say something
definitive as
um yeah if taiwan's attacked we're going
to use our troops and we're going to
defend them and then the White House
going uh no that our policy hasn't
changed it's not what he meant like I've
never four times and and this is this
has happened I've never seen a president
walked back so much if they're coming
like oh hey the pandemic's over and then
everybody in the administration's like
ah not really like no if he's wrong if
he's that he's the pr he's supposedly
the resident of the United States he
should actually be if his word should be
Bond if if he says something that's it
it shouldn't be I mean it just under
first of all if no matter what he says
he's being undermined he's being
undermined by his own people so that
makes him look that's what I'm talking
about and the same thing with Taiwan I
mean if if China wants to to uh attack
Taiwan do you think do you think that
they're going to take Biden at his word
or they're going to go with the
administration it's not going to do
anything do you know the news cycle that
was the Catalyst for Joe Biden's
approval writing going underwater yeah
Afghanistan boom yeah and so you know I
want to believe that regular people
aren't don't care too much about foreign
policy but I think that shows that was
huge the failure of Joe Biden's foreign
policy made a huge impact um because it
was the biggest news story of the year I
mean everything was the whole that whole
thing was covered and I think if we
didn't lose the those 13 service members
it his approval rating he might have
been he might have been able to go you
know what we we got out sure we left a
bunch of stuff behind but we got out and
nobody died oh you know a bunch of
people died he bombed an aid worker and
he tried to blame as Isis K and it
wasn't even an I said K member it was
like yeah it's providing water to
Afghanistan yeah oh and the New York
Times you know they did an amazing uh
wrap-up of of those events a great
article great video uh but the fact that
we just like droned a bunch of kids for
no reason for oh it's a uh it's an Isis
K analyst or something they're they're
uh what was the I forgot what it was it
was like some kind of like engineer or
something and then it it wasn't it was a
guy with putting water in the back of
his car you know and and nobody nobody
was held responsible that's the thing
that that kills me Joe Biden goes well
I'm going to take responsibility for if
I make a mistake and then uh with with
Afghanistan or you're gonna take
responsibility well that was weeks ago
it was just four or five weeks ago come
on man people falling from that didn't
happen the board is secure well it's
very low right now like every nothing
nothing is his fault like like with the
gas prices he you know he's like I
released all this stuff from the
Strategic uh oil petroleum Reserve I did
it I lowered those gas prices and then
they're calling back up and he's like
you gas stations you need to you need to
lower your prices I'm stopping I'm price
gouging I'm beyond thinking any of this
is a coincidence well but with
Afghanistan nobody nobody was held
responsible for for that for that drone
strike for for for everything the the
the terrible pull out they're they're
celebrating it notice that that he was
like oh I did it I pulled him out it's
like no Trump trump said an emotion and
there were conditions and those
conditions were not met when we left
the Taliban was supposed to actually be
in uh in negotiations with the Afghan uh
government that was supposed to be
happening and it didn't and Biden pulled
out anyway because he wanted a photo op
on 9 11. no I think it was intentional I
think that that partly but I think it
was basically sabotage you don't you
don't flee Bagram without notifying the
the security forces unless you
intentionally want the Air Force Base
they're too busy trying to get their
troops to read anti-racist baby but but
will the will the voters remember this
in this upcoming midterm in the next
coming election I I haven't seen a lot
of it a lot of people are not going to
be reminded of it I think social media
is hiding a lot of relative information
to this but when it comes to what's
happening right now I think that has
everyone's attention what's happening in
Ukraine what's happening in Russia is on
everyone's peer review everyone's
talking about this talking about it
everyone's talking about the possibility
of a nuclear war and according to a
Quincy poll 57 percent of U.S voters
strongly or somewhat support the U.S
pursuing diploma negotiations as soon as
possible when it comes to the war in
Ukraine so that that's not really that
much of a strong number it's kind of 50
50 57 is not that much but the problem
is that the Biden Administration keeps
saying that we are not going that
officially we're not going to be part of
those negotiations that it has that it
that it all is on zelinski but that's
not true because the Western World
influences the negotiations but they
keep saying that that's what that that
put us out of it but that's not true
that's what well that's their official
thing yeah yeah but that's not that's
not true at all because obviously this
is a proxy war this is a war between
major Global powers that are saying you
know what we're going to fight it out
we're going to fight it out here in
Ukraine just like they did in Syria just
like they did in many other places
around the world like Libya and we could
keep going on and on I mean it's been
going on for a long time yeah yeah
Vietnam Korea the the Cold War hasn't
really ended it's kind of prolonged here
with a lot of this kind of
neo-conservative project object for a
new American Think Tank policy that
really has taken over American foreign
policy ever since 2001.
at least it's been Go I mean 1946 really
the new with the world liberal economic
order they've been figuring out how to
create limited Wars all over Earth to
keep the war machine strong but to keep
nuclear bombs in the pocket so that
they're not used
uh but but again when it comes to what's
happening domestically how how do you
think Americans uh since it's you cover
a lot of domestic stuff what what where
is foreign policy on the American
priority list according to firm you know
all the research and all the stuff does
it come up is it even important or is it
is it an afterthought for the average
American I think the average American is
more worried about their pocketbook and
what's happening around the kitchen
table as Joe Biden says well let's uh
let's let's bring it back to the United
States here with this story Greg Bryce
tweets so a group of people just
randomly decided to ransack a Wawa in
Northeast Philly tonight check out this
video
all stupid
so like yo you're gonna give me my
sandwich she says are you guys making
food
so these guys are all just basically
ransacking everything I don't know if I
I think I got photos of the aftermath
first next article but first of all we
are all that girl if we're hungry we
want our stuff done hurry up hurry up
I'm hungry there you go look at this
it's getting crazy now look at this one
chick twerking she's she's twerking up
there it's usually just one she's just
twerking you know seeing that you're not
getting your sandwich all right you know
that is the only option you got if
you're really hangry maybe they were
hangry Maybe
here's the video of the aftermath the
whole place is just ransacked and not
only did they ransick but outside
they're fighting each other yeah and
then jumping on jumping on cars and
destroying people's cars that were
parked in the park this is why we left
Philly America is safe guys American
cities are safe it's not called Philly
it's called Philadelphia all right now
you guys ready for the uh for the hammer
drop okay you want to read that one Luke
Philadelphia mayor signs executive order
banning guns from city parks that'll do
it
rampant murders happening in
Philadelphia because criminals who are
committing murder don't care about the
gun laws and people are just rampaging
through these stores
the the mayor is like I got an idea the
people who are obeying the law should be
restricted in from defending them from
defending themselves or stopping other
criminals from of course hurting them
with the firearms that they always
illegally carry since of course
criminals don't follow laws so anyway
anyway he's trying to make people feel
better in city parks okay
come on it's stopping it's like this
no no but it's like think about what
this policy actually means criminals are
murdering people they're breaking the
law they don't care about your laws so
the mayor goes and now law-abiding
citizens will have no right to defend
themselves it's like he saw the news and
then said I need to help these criminals
and that's the policy you get yeah
absolutely how else can you excuse it
other than innocent law-abiding citizens
will now be punished you don't
understand the city parks are safe now
hmm yeah but the rest of the city maybe
not now look at this wait wait let me
let me play the sandwich thing I think
she I think this is what she asked for
the sandwich
did y'all making food
what would you have me do we're being
raided every possession is being taken
away from us in this very moment and
she's like are y'all gonna record or
gonna make me some food no it's a it's a
shame that they don't have Publix in
Philadelphia because they make they make
the best sandwiches the best friendly oh
yeah it takes they have like horrible
vax mandates and fire people and
discriminate against them no that was
Florida oh no no wasn't that public no
Publix uh the opposite or was there
another one no no no Publix there was a
a big hullabaloo with Publix because the
the Press was saying oh well the the
owner of Publix or some executive there
contributed to desantis's campaign and
then when when the vaccine was available
they said oh why don't we distribute the
vaccine at Publix and we're like oh no
they're they're getting like a
sweetheart deal it's like no because
it's just like a Publix everywhere yeah
and so it's easy if you want the vaccine
just find a Publix like they're
everywhere so it's a supermarket chain
right uh but the best Sanders it'll take
an hour to make a sandwich at Publix I'm
pretty sure
the float shot
like what Miami right is Miami
Florida's like really good on gun rights
and they're they're okay
and you need a permit to conceal carry
all right let's let's just be clear I
don't see any guns
not in Florida you can open carry in
Florida if you're going hunting yes no
I'm pretty sure you've got an idea to
buy a gun I don't know uh you could buy
a gun yeah but open carry uh is is
concealed carries allowed but not open
carry oh so you can conceal carry if
just if you get the permit no I don't
know yeah you could continue carry if
you got the permit yeah Florida's not
the best when it comes to guns rights
yeah trust me I had to go through a long
application and and like a whole test
they're trying to change it though right
like they can see they don't just tried
to push constitutional carry but it
didn't go through in the local houses
West Virginia we don't get hurricanes
and you can carry guns with just an ID
but is there state income tax yes oh
yeah so but I'll take Florida I like
Florida yeah Florida man just like
myself we love Florida Governor is
trying to get rid of it and it's the
legislature that won't that's blocking
him he's trying to eliminate the state
income tax West Virginia you know what
to do yeah eliminated and then for those
Western Maryland counties they're trying
to secede to join West Virginia so wow
there you go yeah I mean Philadelphia is
somewhere that I definitely don't think
anyone will want to move to I don't know
if you guys seen some of the videos that
people have been posting just walking
around Philadelphia showing the Havoc
showing the the drug abuse showing the
open-air drug dens that are in that city
axios is even reporting that uh that
that uh gun robberies have gone up 60
since last year uh robberies up 50 so
it's just absolutely Bonkers to see
these latest crime stats and the Mayors
is focusing on on discriminating against
individuals for for trying to be able to
defend themselves in the Parks which is
absolutely freaking crazy it's nuts but
I wonder this crime is a big deal and we
just had the story where Kareem
Jean-Pierre who's just like really bad
at her job awful was asked about crime
and then they were like dude does Biden
think cities are safe and she was not a
yes or no answer I mean it's like just
are you kidding man learn to spin the
answer is yes but I didn't think the
cities are safe because he's been
putting in a lot of work to reduce crime
and while we have seen a spike they are
starting to come down just spin it spin
it but she's just terrible at her job
but anyway she did she did two things
she to to expand and she she did say oh
it's a yes or no question it's not a yes
or no question but then she keeps saying
oh well with the American Rescue plan we
gave so much money in funding to police
officers and firefighters and all these
people to help keep our city safe but
she can't answer whether the cities are
actually safe because of that funding
it's amazing so I mean she she's so
awful at her job and and everybody
thought that jensaki was like a smug
um you know what but at least she could
actually speak English and and not
but you know the funny is awful the
funniest thing about jensaki is that the
way they have the camera on her you'd
assume she was like five eight and she's
like five one yeah she's very very short
and I don't mean that in any way
disrespectful I just think it's
interesting how the camera angles will
like Point upwards so you assume she's
This Tall Person well she also wears
like pretty big heels too because when
you see 15-inch platforms when you see
them walking into the it's like when she
goes when she used to go like hi
everybody and then she walks in and says
you know she's gonna Circle back you
know
you actually you know what's funny about
that just just as a side note I did a
video pointing out that she would say
I'm in a circle back like you know a
whole bunch of times then she stopped
saying it no I think because because of
you I think because people are like yeah
you're really getting hit hard on this
circle back thing you've got to stop
using that phrase I think what happened
was that she is a big fan of yours
she watched your video and she was she
was hurt and she like cried a little bit
because she's like my favorite show and
he's making fun of me uh oh sure
oh sure I'm sure that uh I'm I would I
would have to say that I I I think that
AOC and her staff knew who I was because
I was a very early adopter on YouTube
like there were nobody was doing videos
on ASC before I did and uh and I went
like on an off day to Washington and I
went to her office and the office was
locked like everybody's closed and I
just you know took some pictures in
front of uh the little plaque and I saw
her old Chief of Staff uh shy cot yeah
shockerbody he was he was walking down
the hallway and he he kind of shot me a
look like so they knew they knew who I
was they were like sitting on YouTube
and they're just like grumbling they're
like oh man she like grifter well yeah
well well none that well definitely not
a grifter come on you know I believe I
actually believe what I have to say
other than you know
Hunter Evelyn I'm sorry
um you okay though yeah I'm fine thank
you yeah so uh but yeah I think I think
a lot of people
um do you think a lot of people in
Washington watch
your show yes
that's it expand that's it yes no okay
okay well you we we get requests a lot
we get tons of PR companies hitting us
up about politicians and I just kind of
like
yeah politicians man like when you know
when you guys have Marjorie Taylor green
on like she's she's great she is she's
great she and she's smart and and she's
I I hate how the media tries to paint
her as like this dumb broad she's she's
smart and she's genuine and I really
like that and I just want to give a
shout out to you
um Congress congresswoman and and
Marjorie people like Marjorie Taylor
Grant and Carrie like by all means
disagree with their politics they'll
come in here for three hours and talk
about whatever you ask them and and I
like we can ask pretty absurd questions
yeah DMT graphene you name it we got
into it and the graphing must have been
you right yeah
intelligence agencies in Epstein we
talked about it all which is awesome I
say bring the nastiest serious
politician in here sit him down right
here let's have a good conversation yeah
but the problem is
there have been some politicians we've
had on and it's just like not good right
because you'll be like what do you
because they'll because they'll go full
politician you'll be like do you think
that you know we should have guns blah
blah and they'll go well I think it's an
interesting question you know the issue
is and you're like yeah you know but it
was funny when I think I think Kerry
Lake we asked her about nuclear weapons
and she was I was like should you think
people should have a right to have a new
I think it was care like I'm not sure
because I'm like do think two-way
protects your right to have nuclear
weapons and like they have no problem
like no and then I'm like okay well I
think it does and it's just like you
have a real conversation and I'm not
saying people should have nuclear
weapons but if people could have you
know privateers with Bara like a wall of
cannons yeah why would they now all of a
sudden but more importantly it literally
does case in point private companies can
apply for nuclear weapons if you have
what is it class was it level three FFL
or whatever what does it look I I'm not
sure to be honest with you there's like
certain levels of federal firearms
licensing you can get and you can get an
application for a nuclear weapon because
private companies make these things he's
got lie for it so it does protect your
right to have them and the US government
is incompetent and has lost a number of
nuclear weapons a lot of people don't
even know this but yeah why should we
trust the government with it when they
can't even uh hold them legitimately and
they lost them on record which is
absolutely crazy so which corporations
have nuclear weapons any anybody want to
pontificate probably Northrop Grumman
Halliburton Boeing Lockheed Martin
Raytheon Oh I thought you were talking
like you know McDonald's Macy's
Sears you better you better raise our
stock otherwise we'll unleash and now
and now that serious is you know it's
like almost gone you know all their
nuclear weapons are on the black market
yeah no they're just like rotting and
silos but uh speaking of gun control and
what's going on with crime I need to
bring you now to this story from the
Independent the the pigs now we can say
our upcoming film the pigs cometh is
based on a true story
feral pigs torment residents of New
Zealand Capital Wellington city council
says feral pig population in suburbs has
been expanding so that's just the gist
of the story the people who live in
Wellington New Zealand are apparently
what's going on Ian they're being
attacked by pigs yeah somebody lost like
40 goats or something to pigs in the
last month or so oh the pigs
quote it's a murder scene according to
this one witness wow so so we're
planning a movie called the pigs cometh
and the idea was it's like New York City
and there's like all they like it starts
with them being like ah the mayor hereby
Proclaim all guns are banned and then
everyone's like yay and then it shows
the cops like just like grabbing guns
and all the gangs are turning their guns
in and then everyone's like we've we've
done it the guns are gone and then all
of a sudden they see like a pig like in
the distance just like eating garbage
and they're like What's that they're
like it's just a pig don't worry and
then the Pig turns real quick and then
touch running full speed at the crowd
and they're like ah and then the whole
movie's like this horror film where
they're like what do we do how do we
stop the pigs I have no idea then the
pigs are just rampaging and that was the
idea for the film we had and then before
the show Ian told me it's actually
happening so now we can say based on a
true story and wait did we did did the
New York City residents get rid of
knives and and uh axes and you you might
might be a little no no no no no no no
no they don't exist in this world are
you joking you think you're gonna fight
50 feral Hogs with a knife good luck bro
dude apparently they're about they range
up to 260 pounds
all right dude yeah all right let's
let's see how you handle like a whole
heavy weight on all four that's a great
plot topics the the the 250 pound boar
is just like
the guy goes I've got a steak knife and
then he gets mauled by the pig but
you've seen First Blood right Rambo yeah
the first the first Rambo movie no he's
in he's in the woods he's hungry and and
he he takes his knife
anybody can climb up a tree
and and tie a knife to a stick and then
jump down perfectly uh and and uh kill
abort and then strip it and eat it
anybody can do that I think anybody can
technically uh just depends on if they
if they're if they actually yeah pigs
could be like 300 plus pounds New York
the New Yorkers Yorkers are very
resources look at this look at the story
from the guardian it's a murder scene
feral pigs torment residents in New
Zealand Capital don't they like heavily
regulate guns in New Zealand
marauding feral pigs have blighted
essential suburb in New Zealand's
Capital the summer from Brooklyn it says
Brooklyn not New Zealand you're reading
that oh Brooklyn okay what I'm I'm
trying to make a joke oh it's just a
suburb of Brooklyn in New Zealand
a suburb of Wellington yeah oh not New
York yeah it's a suburb of Brooklyn I
was just making a joke oh did I read it
I'm not no I'm I'm making a joke you're
fine I'm sorry oh okay all right anyway
the pig night everybody look at this a
boar killed in a ghost holy crap
so if a kid can kill a boar no no in
your scale yeah the kid's just happy
it's the kids the penny next to the uh
okay all right so so but in all
seriousness as they're banning guns
across the board the gag that I'm like
the joke I'm making is
it's not really a joke it's like you ban
weapons
then what do you do when wild animals
show up because this is a thing like
these people in big cities are like guns
should be banned nobody needs more than
you know if you're a hunter and you need
more than 10 rounds you're up you had
Hunter and it's like oh okay so in like
four wild boars Rampage through your
property and they all weigh 200 pounds
tell me that 10 rounds is enough I feel
like the
Lake Gibson's episode where where
everybody collected all the guns and
then something happened where they
needed guns the Family Guy did it maybe
it was uh like a Halloween episode or
something but a Family Guy maybe the
chat can you know it knows what I'm
talking about it might be Family Guy but
Peter melts down all the plumbing to
make guns and then the townsfolk are
like it's a post-apocalyptic and they're
like you got rid of our plumbing for
guns and he goes that's right and then
they throw him and and his the Griffins
out of the city and then radioactive
Stewie babies when they go to the
Twinkie factory yeah so that was yeah
that was a Twinkie factory and the
stewies the tentacles go and attack
everybody and the guys like quick grab
the guns and they're on finals I can't
and then Stewie kills them all there's
another episode where the guns were
turned into a statue celebrating
non-violence and then an invading Army
came in and then took over everyone and
they couldn't uh I forgot which which uh
which is that Simpsons I I think that
could have been the Simpsons people in
the chat room will let us know them
thank you thank you right now dude some
people are saying to look up Hogzilla uh
someone already probably even made that
movie so I was just looking this up and
there is a hypothetical one thousand
pound hog that they killed somewhere in
the U.S and I don't think that's or I
think it might have been in Russia and I
don't think it was ever proven but
there's like a picture they thought
might have been forced perspective this
is North Carolina
2014. there's one like in Turkey that's
a dinosaur that's not a uh I want to see
you with your butter knife Andrew handle
that let's see what you could do there
that's a vicious murderous mammal like
that will kill a human kind kind of
thing it's like a bear but faster it's
dead so what happened no bears can go
like 35 miles bears are pretty nice but
it says Alabama boy bags wild hogs
regularly with 450 Bushmaster so you can
give a kid proper training and a
powerful enough rifle he can take down
that monster you take away the guns good
luck anyone that's the thing about guns
it's a great equalizer right well
whether you're a five foot tall woman or
a six foot seven pure lean muscle man if
you're going to get into a conflict that
gun normalizes the fight between them
well then you have all the larpers and
everything that have uh swords and so
swords still exist in your world right I
mean it's a good idea so like while the
pigs are rampaging around some
cosplayers jump out and they strike a
pose with their swords but their swords
are fake you know because it's like we
have some fake swords and we have some
real swords or those Minecraft uh sponge
swords you see it uh the foam swords
okay all right well you know we're we're
gonna I wanted an executive producer uh
here's the best part
the McGuffin is that someone finds a box
of bullets and they're like we have to
get this to the HQ where they have the
last gun and they have to like travel
across all of Manhattan with marauding
pigs everywhere and that's like the item
to like you have to get it and it's like
the ring and then they get it and then
they're like they get to the the guy's
house and he's like I was able to save
one rifle and it's like a it's like a
it's like a um
like a civil war right no no no no like
it's got to be like a standard like you
know something like an M1 it's got to be
able to just you know oh okay maybe
maybe it'll be like a bolt action 308 it
was like in a museum from World War yeah
there you go or something yes yeah and
then it's like you know it's a single
load bolt action or something but it's
all they got and then with that they're
able to stop the pigs one by one one
shot at a time I'm looking at stats on
Hogzilla apparently scientists Zoom the
corpse and they found it to be about 800
pounds uh between seven and eight and a
half feet long
and uh it's it was a hybrid between a
wild boar and a domestic Pig whoa and
the tusks were about two feet they were
longer than two feet each they're 28
inches each
so one was 28 inches one was 19 inches
so the different lengths of Tusk the
funny thing about this is that Meme
where the left was like we're gonna ban
guns and the guy was like what do I do
and you know 15 to 30 feral Hogs right
you know attack my property or whatever
and then all the Liberals were like
laughing like you're so dumb hugs and
everybody who lives in the middle of
nowhere was like uh-huh so what this
some quotes from the person that's
dealing with the hog infestation said
about they lost about 60 goats in the
last few months and what happens is if
they quote if they find something they
like eating meaning the Hogs and it's a
free feed meaning a newborn kid which is
a baby goat they're gonna keep coming
back so it's just it's just over and
over and over again these swarms of
gigantic muscular beasts come
slaughtering uh yeah you need guns for
that
get big and they're dangerous that's it
period but people are so used to living
in luxury with security and bricks and
bridges and all of the wonders of the
modern world that they've not
experienced look you know where these
stories come from about monsters of
Legend we have these stories in like
ancient myth of giant beasts being
fought by Noble Heroes and it's like
this giant monster slang a dragon it's
because way back in the day some dude
was in a tribe of like 70 people and
he's like I'm going to go find berries
and there's walking through the forest
and he comes across some like 70 pound
pig and he's like oh it's a pig and then
he grabs a stick and he's whacking it
and the pig's biting at him and then he
cracks a second stabs it and wins then
he comes back goes I defeated a great
monster and he tells this story and then
everyone's imagining and they write it
down and the story passes down and then
eventually it's a gigantic 10 foot tall
you know Pig Beast you know what I mean
but we also always sit there eight feet
long on the heart if they stand up and I
mean if they're 800 pounds the giant
spiders I mean that that stuff probably
used to exist until Humanity
extinctified at all but it's but it's
like somebody's walking down the road
traveling to the to the city to trade
some beans or something and then he
fought a bear and it was like a
medium-sized bear and he barely survived
and he comes back and he's bleeding and
he's like I killed a giant Beast must
have been seven feet tall and then the
story is told nowadays
people don't go wander off in the woods
for the most part people still get
killed by like mountain lions and stuff
but the average person living in a city
has no idea how dangerous it is to be
out in the middle of nowhere I'll tell
you this man we're by the Appalachian
Trail go out during a new moon and stand
on that trail and you will be freaked up
out well like coyotes the weird noises
the rustling the creatures that can see
you and you can't see them it's pitch
black yeah that's one of those no Jersey
things oh yeah you're ncu you're in the
woods so we went out uh last year during
a new moon
we're on our bikes and it's pitch black
on the Forest Trail and so we stopped
and turned the lights off and you hear
like things circling you you hear like
the rustling running around you and
you're like you know something's
something's going on they're probably
scared of you who knows but you hear
weird noises weird like hooting and I'm
like I got no idea everything is Pitch
Black you turn the bikes on turn the
lights on and we just sped off it was
fun but it was freaky now imagine most
people live in a situation like that
would probably be in favor of guns which
is probably why we have 2A because back
then it is dangerous Pig could Rampage
to the town someone had to shoot it and
their guns weren't even that good these
days everybody lives in a city they're
they're in their concrete cubicle it
smells like sour milk and they never see
these pigs but the problem is wait so
what's the name of this movie the pigs
cometh Okay so
let me get it straight the the first
movie set in a city and then the pigs
cometh again
that's the one that's set in the woods
there's not what we can do you're doing
a sequel sure you're setting up the
sequel you know the the you know the the
animals
yeah they have to go find the source of
the pigs deep underground now all of
them yes all the urban Liberals are like
armed and muscular from fighting the
pigs and now they know and they're like
the only way we bring back peace is to
destroy the Hogs from The Source the
source of China but there's we gotta dig
underground to get there the source is
Hogzilla it's like
let's talk
all night hey let's talk about the
modern world I want to pull up the story
because we'll talk about what's going on
this is from New York Post act your wage
is the new quiet quitting visibility
doesn't pay the bills say gen Z workers
yo the future is yours for the taking
gen Z not all of them but they are such
lazy vapid spineless and pathetic
individuals this is what your wealth
hath wrought could you imagine going to
like the greatest generation and being
like if you fight this war you will you
will make this and them being like well
that's a noble cause let's do it they're
gonna be like wow
that's sad
these gen Z workers are saying don't let
them see you doing anything and just do
nothing and get paid because you're
worth it
what do you think Andrew
um is that a fair depiction money is a
human right or something like I this the
I've heard all about this this you know
the quiet quitting and I've talked about
uh with friends about people actually
working like going back to work in an
office and
um
you know I was watching uh last night
Tucker Carlson was interviewing Dana
White and he was like yeah like you know
a couple weeks after the beginning of
the pandemic everybody came back to the
office and was working in the office
and
there's there's a lot to say about
working in an office because you can
it's easier to micromanage your team
it's easier to say uh get your work done
as opposed to I'll just keep moving your
mouse like every 15 minutes while you're
you're showering and cooking and playing
with your cat you know uh it's it's
almost I think at the beginning of the
pandemic a lot of people were were
worried about losing their jobs I'm
working at home I need to show my boss
that I'm actually doing stuff now we're
having this this debate whether you
should you know work your worth or
you're working too much for for less
money it's just it's it's all ridiculous
all of this
from remember van life that was really
big yeah yeah I'm just like
uh well let me slow down there was this
woman who made two videos and got like
two million subs and they said it was an
it was a mistake in the algorithm or
something and I'm just yes I'm like it's
really convenient that there's a
movement forming telling people to sell
off all their positions and live in
squalor at a time when they're also
campaigning against climate change I'm
sorry it just doesn't sound like a
coincidence it sounds like they
intentionally prioritized talking about
how cool it is to live in a van
would it be great to have nothing I bet
the algorithm you'll own nothing and
you'll be happy and then they're like
wait where do I poop and then like this
is horrible
you have an RV and you have an RV do you
have an RV I built a van and it's got a
full functioning uh black water system
with a toilet and a shower and
everything yeah like you know a human
being like you're you know you guys
pointed you guys have you guys have a
decent amount of income that you can do
that not everybody can uh can take a
sprinter van that's not that's not the
point that's what I'm trying to make it
I'm sorry YouTube was promoting people
giving up their possessions to live in a
van something about it is charming
though I've always kind of had the
desire to like hop in a motorhome and
tour the planet you know in my
retirement my old age or whatever but
then the realism is that it's hard to
get stuff done well here let me let me
ask you guys uh how do you feel
personally about the debate that you
know people should you know oh nothing
corporations want people to work in an
office in their space
workers either want hybrid or they want
to completely stay home and they think
that they deserve it they think that
that's yeah and and if they don't get it
they're going to quit and they're
they're going to quietly quit good they
should they should so and companies
should be happy
if you're a corporation if you're yeah
if you're in your employees are like I
won't come to the office and be like
exactly we're letting you go and best of
luck and both parties will be very happy
in that scenario because if you're
running a company I'll tell you this
because we need this here too you want
your employees in a space to build a
culture to share ideas and help develop
I like everything that's happening in
the space so we get people hitting us up
being like I can do that job but I'll do
it remotely I said we can't do it
and they go like well I'm looking for a
remote good luck man you know best of
luck to you we're looking for people who
want to come down and and help build
something and that means no matter what
your job is someone might be like I'm
working on this game and you could be
like oh yeah try this I'm like I didn't
think about that that's the kind of
stuff that can only happen when people
are hanging out together that are
friends that are working together to
build something you can't do these
things over slack or teams it's not the
same thing and it's an environment that
also challenges you and inspires you
when you see someone next to you working
really hard it inspires me to work even
harder so even coming here when I'm when
I'm not here I'm I take things a lot
easier but when I'm here I'm seeing
everyone work and I'm like okay I gotta
step it up I gotta you know put all my
intentions and put all my energy into
being the best version of myself as you
could clearly see I'm doing a lot of
that and and and and I'm only getting
better as time goes on because I'm
around that environment so I I think a
lot of these you know young people
they're being taught a lot of really bad
things in college and when they hit the
real world they're kind of devastated
because one they're in debt two they're
also in a situation where they're going
to have to work for a corporation or a
situation that they're not going to be
happy about so I I think this is why
we're seeing it correlated and now I'm
sorry Tim we're we're in we're about to
what nothing are you talking about your
boots
I mean we're we're on the we're in a
recession and it's only going to get
worse and all these people that that
overpaid uh on homes paid like two
hundred thousand dollars more for a
house than it was worth they're gonna
lose their jobs and then we're gonna
have a major housing crisis so oh man
this is the crazy thing right now let me
tell you we uh you know we're we're
we're working on expansion I got good
news two of the walls at Freedom of Stan
are up on the new on the new
headquarters it's steel frame building
and paid in cash
well what do you mean you didn't take
out a mortgage yeah there you go yeah
yeah we hired a company to build a
building yes and so you you basically
you pay by invoice though so they're
like we bought this then you got to pay
them so over a period of time you're
you're paying in cash it's not like you
write a check for a million dollars and
hand it to them or anything like that
right but we got two of the walls up
this is really good news the other thing
is we've been talking about doing a
brick and mortar shop and so I've been
look I've been I've been looking at
various properties the funniest thing in
the world they just raised interest
rates
and all of these property owners for
some reason are convinced their
properties are worth 50 more than
they're worth so I go to I go to this
building and they're like you know they
want x amount of money and I'm like are
you nuts like there's a labor shortage a
supply shortage we're in a recession
we're in a bear Market they just raise
interest rates they're going to raise
interest rates again and you think I'm
gonna give you that price and they go
you know what we're gonna wait what
happens two months goes by the rates go
up the price drops and I come back to
them and I say I told you what it was
worth you could have sold it I'm
inclined to offer you less but these
it's just insane right now that prices
are dropping across the board property
is popping up everywhere because rates
are going up but there are still these
people who are convinced that their
empty lot is worth millions of dollars
and it's laughable and you're like
you've been on the market for two years
I'm just you know that's that's sort of
a you know anyway behind the scenes the
kind of thing but what I want to say
right now is when it comes to these gen
Z people being like this is what the
story says from New York Post this this
woman Sarai Marie
acts out this the scene where she goes
hey Veronica I'm gonna have you take
this home and work on it tonight and
then she goes respectfully Susan I'd
rather spend time with my family
slurping an iced coffee from Starbucks
okay well look to be honest if you're a
wage worker I totally agree with that if
you're being paid by the hour and your
boss comes to you and says I want you to
take this project back home and finish
it you'll be like okay well I'll bill
you by the hour so if I'm if I'm working
for you and you're paying me hourly then
I'll say We'll commit four hours to my
home time and it's time and a half over
time sure and then you know okay but
what they're talking about with a lot of
these young people is not wages but
salaries look I'm excited some you know
how he we hire here I don't care about
people who want to do a job I care about
funding people who are already like
living that life like what I mean is
somebody might be like I want to write a
book and I'm working on these stories
I'll be like okay I'm gonna give you
money to keep doing that that's what I'm
interested in somebody so instead of
being like
we want someone to do the job it's more
like do you like doing this thing you do
how would you like to get paid to do
that thing yeah I've noticed the people
that work here that that works out are
leaders like self-incline and that
you're facilitating leaders to function
in the thing that they do well when
people come and they're waiting to be
told what to do it's not the right
environment and so that's that's the
thing with these people if you ever get
somebody who's like I'm Gonna Act my
wage and quietly quit it's like okay
you're fired you know no beef I mean
we're letting you go because you clearly
don't want to be here I tell everybody
if you don't want to be here you
shouldn't be you know if you want to be
here then you know we'll make it we'll
figure it out what I identify with with
people's disgruntled uh nature right now
is hourly wages for things that can be
done like you're here for 40 hours a
week and just sit there and we'll give
you things to do through the day and I'm
like because I would get things to do
and they'd I could get them done super
fast and then I'd be like okay I'm done
and they're like well you need to be
here for six more hours and I'm like
damn this is a waste of my life I can
get things done super fast so pay me for
projects that's what I think people need
to start focusing on if you want to
please your employees is pay them per
project doesn't matter how fast they are
in fact it's better if they do it fast
and it gives them more free time that's
the thing too we don't do we don't we
don't do hourly we do all salary and so
it's like if if your job is to like
let's say move box from room a to room B
I don't care how long it takes you to do
it you did it you can leave I don't care
you know just you we got you message me
and if we need anything else this is
your task you did it go watch go play
video games whatever
like it's insane to me that you're gonna
pay me to play video games if I hire you
to paint a picture of bucko the cat and
you get that and and I'm like it's uh
you got to paint this picture and uh I
don't know how long it'll take you but
we'll pay you X and you go okay and then
an hour later it's this beautiful
Masterpiece I'd be like well here's your
pay like now you can do whatever you
want because this was the agreement
these are the terms of the contract you
know what I mean so per project like Ian
said yeah all like sort of so my I mean
maybe it's it's that these people are
looking for that kind of work right
maybe it's that these gen Z people want
the environment where they can focus on
what they want to do sometimes people
get taken advantage of like they'll be
like okay they want me to paint a
picture of bucko they do it an hour it's
done it's amazing and then the owner is
like that's fantastic now paint me
another one and you're like dude I could
have taken eight hours to do this and
then you wouldn't make me do a second
one so like it's like the only show
would work you've shown your hand you
know like you I got an A plus two
minutes we know that you're a super fast
person you know I'm in it as an employer
I'm going to take advantage of that and
say well this I know that he's gonna do
these this great stuff within an hour
and I'm gonna have them do like three or
four of them a day I used to get that in
school I would get all eight pluses when
I was really young and then I started to
get B's because I was just so bored with
homework I kind of didn't want to do
homework and my parents like what's
wrong you get you're an A plus student
what's wrong something's wrong I gotta
see in there you're grounded until you
until you approve your credits and I'm
like I should have just gotten B's and
C's the whole time so I stopped trying I
was like I'm just gonna own in the bare
minimum to get through this [ __ ] and
I did and I've got immensely successful
and I had lots of free time as a result
that was my attitude with school it's
like
the way the school fun way at school
functions is extremely detrimental to
like to to gifted kids to hard-working
kids some kids some people it's a lot
harder to learn stuff and so they're
sitting there and they're struggling so
you punish them for it which makes no
sense some kids solve the problem
instantly so you punish them for it wow
really made no sense so for like I I for
me it was it was similar I'd be in class
and they'd be like today we're going to
learn this subject in math I'd open the
book I'd look I go oh I get it and then
they'd be like do the problem I go oh
yeah it's like this and they would say
okay that's that's Monday but Tuesday
through Friday we're still doing this
Friday is the test I'll be like okay
well I don't need to pay attention to
you mumbling what you already told me so
then I'd be daydreaming or doodling and
not paying attention then the teacher
would think she caught me and be like
you answer the question and I'd answer
the question then I would get punished
because I didn't do the weird nonsense
formula they wanted because I could do
math in my head and so I was just like
at that point school is a complete waste
of time the the purpose of it clearly is
to push people into a box and compress
them
it's not making kids successful it's not
teaching them to be hard-working
individuals who can succeed it's
teaching them to not try to hold
themselves back because you'll only be
punished if you work harder which is why
I'm not surprised this is what we're
getting with the New Gen with the Next
Generation but teaching them to comply
to follow orders it zaps their
creativity and zaps away any kind of
Independence or entrepreneurial spirit
because you're not supposed to draw
outside of the lines you're supposed to
do as you're told and I think a lot of
modern education is just rinse and
repeat instead of hey let's see what
you're naturally gifted in let's see
what you're naturally talented in let's
explore those ideas let's see ways that
we could help the world rather than of
course exploit it for our own personal
benefit
and you know
this this culture this work culture is
just so weird where people feel that
they're you know that they're all that
they belong to work at home do you think
that like somebody comes out of college
has never worked in an office before it
gets a job working from home oh man and
does that person think that they're
going to be working from home until like
they retire like that they're going to
be having that they're that they're
never going to work in an office they're
like I'm this is sustainable this is
something you know this is why everybody
bought all these big houses that they
didn't really need you know uh but it's
just such a it's just the whole thing is
it's such a weird culture and uh it's
the argument the the argument to stay at
home and completely miss those
interactions and completely miss that
inspiration and stuff so just so bizarre
to me like I I loved going into an
office unless I had a terrible boss what
it's probably easy to be like hey do you
want to come work for a big you know
podcast and silly comedy show and ghost
stories that's probably easy to convince
people it's a fun place to be but if
you're like working at the Cracker
Factory I can imagine you don't want to
be there well let's stick well unless
you're passionate about different kind
of crackers but not you know and and
that's and that's another thing uh not
everybody has the privilege to work from
home you can't be a barista and work
from a home you know unless you're
controlling some Barista robot or
something like a drone you know
which maybe you're coming sure uh but
not not everybody has a privilege so to
for for a certain for a select group of
people to be angry about having to go
back to the office think about everybody
else retail workers manufacturing
workers like they don't have that
privilege anyway I wanna I wanna jump
into this next story oh my let me jump
to this story and we have an apology to
make so this is the story a timcast IRL
will be making a formal apology to Ned
Fulmer this is the daily mail saying
married Ned Fulmer is fired from the
popular YouTube show the try guys after
photos of him making out with his
engaged producer or post it online by
her fiance and as you know the try guys
produced that video that revealed their
testosterone levels or the equivalent to
an 80 year old man and we referred to
them as soy boys I would like to
formally apologize because dude is a
player he took him up with all these
chicks they're posting photos man this
guy's all over the place you know so he
has to be on trt absolutely on trt
absolutely there's no way you could
rebound from from that and from what was
it his T levels were that of an 80 year
old absolutely but how do you explain
him having two women at the same time
trt trt yeah okay wait so so the first
one is his wife is that his wife is that
is that his wife okay yeah and then the
second one
um and that's and then Falmer was
exposed cheating with his producer
Alexandria Herring pictured with her
fiance will Thayer when the sharp-eyed
club goer recorded the pair making out
I mean he he's not in horrible shape and
he probably got those medical results
and any kind of uh you know legitimate
doctor would have been like hey this is
serious you got to deal with these low
testosterone numbers as of course low
testosterone is correlated with bone
density mental health physical health
and overall well-being and you can't be
well especially if you're not you know
swole and and and happy and content with
yourself and and have the proper
if you have the proper ability to to be
able to supplicate yourself
real quick before we do that I want to
hold that thought in yeah because when
we were looking into this story and I
was like whoa this is the guy from the
testosterone thing right so BuzzFeed I'm
sorry daily wire says BuzzFeed guys test
their testosterone levels the results
are exactly what you'd expect uh video's
gone oh they took the video down maybe
because they were tired of being called
Low T soy boys but hey man dude's a
player he's looking
if you've got a depleted testosterone
levels because of the phthalates or
whatever you've been done it to yourself
dietarily or whatever then you take trt
to replenish it are you then overly
jazzed like is it going to make you
overly aggressive like is if you're not
getting the Natural Balance and you're
trying to balance it out with X and
Dodge it like external sources well a
medical doctor will check your levels
and make sure that you are supplicating
the right amount to make sure that
you're you're going to be healthy yeah
yeah so supplementing or supplicating
same potato potato you know
again I know what I'm talking about here
you got to take me seriously I have all
the membranes to uh to to to this
conversation means to ask or beg for
something earnestly or humbly yeah yeah
yeah so so the body asks humbly for the
testosterone and then the doctor humbly
gives it to them and then injects them
with it and then and then helps them
specifically humbling and maybe you guys
don't know the answer if say your levels
are at 50 average good levels are 50 but
you're at 20 naturally and you take 30
of external back to 50 is it different
than just naturally being at 50. I don't
know I'd imagine to a certain degree
because it's not the same kind of
testing that's what I'm that's what I'm
wondering is if guys do it to get back
officially you become dependent on it
for the rest of your life Joe Rogan
talks about this and there's certain
individuals that take a lot of
artificial testosterone and some
individuals who who uh you know overdose
on it and and don't dose it correctly
and then have a lot of negative
consequences for it uh that do hurt
their mental and physical state so you
know medical doctor usually uh will help
you get the right amount of swole uh to
to make sure that uh you know you're in
a very healthy physical shape just like
I am just swollen enough yeah just just
so you have the optimal physical the
optimal Soul
now that we got the jokes out of the way
I actually want to point out cheating on
your wife is definitely a low T move
let me think about this think of the
Chad meme like the the gray picture of
the guy with the big chiseled chair and
the and the 12-pack
that Meme I don't think would ever be
applied to a guy cheating on his wife
you know what I mean like what I mean is
cheating on your wife is viewed no and
by the left and the right as an
extremely negative and wrong thing to do
and no one would ever call a cheater a
Chad you know what I mean right like I
mean I'm not saying literally but it's
just like a negative No One's Gonna like
the Chad meme is someone who's
successful and prominent yeah somebody's
calling Adam Levine a Chad right right
yeah it's just like it's scuzzy so for
this guy to be a low-t guy editing his
wife in all reality it's actually just
proves the point that he's a soy boy you
know what I mean but here's here's my my
question
he got fired from the try guys
what about the producer
she's engaged no the show's over oh it
shows over apparently they're canceling
the show oh okay because it didn't it
didn't say I was reading that's so dumb
too it's like you we canceled the show
because of that we cheated on your wife
shows over everybody everyone's fired
shutting it down but there's probably
other things I mean the show is running
for a while they they might have run out
of ideas
um there could be a lot of different
things behind the scenes but again this
is personal drama we don't know the side
of the story of the man the woman the
the person who was in the relationship
there's a lot of complicated things that
that come into relationships oh no no
I'm sorry the show's not over what
Twitter said is the try guys announcing
they're no longer working with their
co-creator Ned Fulmer I thought I saw on
Twitter I just saw the oh okay ellipses
was like they're no longer working I
thought they were saying so he's so he
the co-creator is gone the producer who
is is also uh you know morally what's
the what's the word is it a harlot
what's the word for a woman who is like
she she's like she is the cheat e you
know what I mean there's a word for this
a woman charlatan succubus no Scarlet
Letter no there's like a word for a
woman who sleeps with a man who's
married uh I I don't know if I'm allowed
to say that I don't know well no because
like so so people don't understand on
the show people people assume these
words just mean like one thing like
people think hobo bum vagrant I mean
they mean totally different things oh
totally they literally do no no they do
hobo means Homeward Bound vagrant means
like you're Milling about aimless a bomb
is somebody who doesn't have a job and
so but people think it all means the
same like a homeless person is a hobo
bum or vagrant that's not true and so
there's a word for a woman who I don't
know what it is though I mean everyone's
saying home wrecker Jezebel oh that's a
good one yeah that's a good one yeah
mistress is the word for like what the
guy has yeah I'm going but it might be
Jezebel Mischief Hitler it might be
mistress but mistress I'm thinking
mistress is if a guy has like a woman on
the side other than his wife that's that
mistress that so the one will be the
mistress that would be his mystery he
wasn't married though yes he was oh he
was I thought she was married no she's
engaged she's engaged and he's married
but she still has a job right why why
does she get to stay and he had he a
co-creator because he doesn't have to
leave but but now he and if you scroll
down he he put out an Instagram and he
apologized he puts out an apology saying
oh well you know I should have uh I
should have I should be focusing on my
family and my kids you're like
how's it going to work because this guy
just lost like the thing that he the
biggest thing that he ever created and
you know do you think that's gonna he
doesn't have a job now you think that's
gonna actually work I don't know friend
like you think that that's gonna work
out with his family he's not gonna have
any kind of Reason how much money did he
make off the show who knows it seems
like they have like a lot of people on
their staff so yeah maybe the money
wasn't flowing as much as uh he should
in some other places if after this long
well it's been like a decade of them
doing the show if he's not set for life
with a show that big then you never know
it's a bad money money management well I
mean he he had he made bad life choices
with his that's true you know so maybe
maybe uh there's there's other things
going on that we don't know about well
these are you know personal you know
matters and drama right right you know
it's just like yeah I mean people you
know look people in you know in
Celebrity and they cheat on each other
all the time some you know someone Super
Chat as us the words for the woman
Jezebel okay yes Harlot I thought
homewrecker yes that's home record that
could be a man but they said Brandon up
says I prefer slam Pig
all one word all one word Bravo that
that's that was worth the surprise yeah
that was great
slam slam pig is that is it what does
that mean is that noun a promiscuous
woman typically overweight or ugly is
that the definition for pumping and
dumping end quote uh from dictionary
slam pig is the uh the yes two words to
your movie
again the sequel and the sequel assumes
that you know everything about the first
gameplay
I still can't find the first one
that is a funny idea the pigs cometh two
yeah and it's just like what's the first
one yeah I love it loud well no the pigs
cometh again yeah hopefully this dude
works it out with his family you know
it's not the end of the world honesty is
the key and you can get ahead of it by
being honest with your partner if you
want to have sex with somebody else then
you that's a conversation you should
have before you do it but as the as the
wife do you do you think you know that
you're going to be like oh yeah I
forgive you yet I mean I mean well
that's tough question I remember this
was photos of him making out
we don't know if anything actually
happened beyond that we don't know yeah
maybe there was he was in distress and
couldn't breathe and it was having a
heart attack yes he's giving her mouth
to mouth to help her yeah you know again
with the way the corporate media we
don't know every we don't know all the
details you know she was on the ground
and he's giving her mouth to mouth and
the guy turns the camera sideways to
make it seem like they're up against the
wall we know less about this than the
explosions on uh on uh North Korean
no no or ask it Korean Jean-Pierre would
say uh Nordstrom too Nordstroms that was
that was impressive Nordstrom she's a
very impressive person
oh man you know this feels like the end
of an era
it's like this is it I don't think I've
ever seen a try guys episode in my life
so uh the low but they got like tens of
millions of hits on these videos it was
insane like who watches this stuff I
guess people watch it I got seven point
wait hold on can we pull up their
Channel it says 7.8 million subscribers
what's their like you know view to
subscriber ratio like on a your uh
typical episode there's probably there's
probably a lot now because people are
like oh what what's this try guys thing
about about a million they let's say
they put out a video every few days and
they get you know million and a half 1.6
this one got three we need to talk about
Texas featuring Beto O'Rourke as like uh
313 000 views very low leaves on that
one
surprise surprise yeah this one from two
weeks ago Keith eats everything at Pizza
Hut
wow that's like horrible beats that
you're in centralizing the chai try try
the try guys ruin chocolate eclairs
try guys try colonics
I wonder what that was like I see why
people watch this that's probably
monetized family friendly show yeah
this is like a TV show it's 20 minutes
long one's an hour long it's like fully
produced and everything how many ad
breaks do you think they have I probably
get the premium ads too they probably
get like all the good stuff women get
mammograms for them like solar panel
stuff I wonder what their like biggest
video is most popular the try guys get
their bones cracked oh man he beats
everything at Panera got a ton of views
so the Keith eats everything there
there's a chiropractor uh channel that
does one and my back yeah you know it's
like every month Keith does a new look
at this look at this one look at this
one I like Keith Keith's everything at
KFC and it like what's with his face
it's part of a series dude this guy
beats everything at Panera Bread is that
what time Eugene joined him at Taco Bell
DJ was like I'm in on that virgin Eugene
what oh wow this is oh look man I think
if they make a show people like it you
know good for them it's fine I'm not
drunk versus high that's pretty okay hey
chat chat do you guys like regularly
watch the try guys let us know let us
know in the chat please press one if you
have to press two if no here's here's
the thing about it it's like we're
saying X for doubt we're sitting here
going like uh who watches this stuff and
they get like substantially more views
than we yeah Keith eats everything they
actually like Red Lobster yeah
four million views wait where what
really that's six months ago are you
kidding no no 3.9 defeats everything at
Olive Garden he's just just taken
advantage who is this magic man named
Keith how many years are you gonna keep
doing this brother
Carl's Jr oh eat everything by living
out of childhood fantasy yeah but the
truth is you really can't because a lot
of the food there is just mix and match
of other Foods so it's like is he eating
like a bowl of parsley and then eating a
noodle and then eating a piece of
chicken ORS because you can order like
50 different noodle dishes which are
just combinations you know what I mean
the series finale is Keith eats
everything at a grocery store Keith
regurgitates everything he ate in the
last year everyone in the chat room is
is typing in two majority they don't
watch okay look I know you're shocked to
be fair the try guys get comparable
views to just this show alone but in
terms of like the Tim cast chose they
get substantially less well look I mean
they have seven they have 7.8 million
subs and they're getting
they're they're getting 28 million to
watch a guy eat so I mean that's pretty
good oh no 2.8 2.8 million how are they
gonna do the show without Ned they're
done I don't know it's over that is kind
of demoralizing yeah
everyone's saying they don't watch all
right well we gotta go to super chats oh
yeah because uh super chats are I think
Keith is probably the heartbeat of that
show that's the whenever I thought a try
guys I'd always think of Keith that's
that's the memorable face I would
remember
so I think as long as he's involved I
think the show will continue strong okay
well I was watching a documentary about
epic meal time do you guys remember that
yeah yeah Harley yeah and apparently
like everybody left the show and then
the views started collapsing it's like
it just show didn't work anymore I guess
there's only so much like so many times
you can jam a bunch of cheeseburgers in
a pan and pork cheese on it that's a
rough that's not a sustainable model no
you need to evolve or die there's one of
this guy who got really obese you know
the YouTube YouTuber that he would eat
like right he died right no I don't
think so I was just watching a video
about refrigerator I'm sorry what's that
refrigerator Meg man I don't have the
guy I'm out to pull it up later on
Family Guy Meg started just eating a
bunch of random stuff and got really
really fat and then she got uh her feet
were cut off from diabetes and then uh
you remember this episode I don't watch
and then she becomes an uh an influencer
sponsored by pancresta which is like a
harsh narcotic that turns you into a
ball of pure light energy
that's family wow all right all right
what a great show
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends and uh become a member at
timcast.com we're gonna have that
members only uncensored show coming up
at about 11 pm you don't want to miss it
be the notification my friends oh whoa
what was that Luke oh Luke you're still
looking good look what's happening wow
oh my gosh what are you touching over
there are you are you okay should I call
an ambulance
like something pop moment to myself
oh my gosh have some respect it actually
scared me I was like what just happened
and then I was like Oh no you're being
swatted again let me see oh look oh oh
okay oh okay wow all right a little uh
you know lift and separate wow
completely normal guys
he looks great he's stunning and brave
that's right all right all right what do
we got here the master of violence says
special request for the guest can you
sing the JG Wentworth jingle
um I I know you can't it's copyrighted
and we're gonna get in trouble moving on
what the answer is
uh to be uh just just so you know we
sang it before the uh we did we sang it
and I even did the low voice if you have
an annuity and you okay
stop everything oh you were yeah
yeah what's what's the one all the way
at the bottom there uh R.I.P to lose oh
no that's an old one yeah this is what
okay that's a master of violence thank
you for for that we had we had fun
yesterday Luke got a guy that was from
yesterday I couldn't read it all right
what do we got here
Fisher Kingston says I think they're
wrong about Ian's path there's a
corridor of least resistance in the jet
stream passing over Melbourne to the
east coast be safe
well all right cool take it seriously
does that Sun have something to do with
the Hogs
no the hurricane
because you know new New Zealand is
close to
all right Jeremy mcdude says when a
nation like Germany have anything to
gain from sabotaging the pipeline is it
in an area where there's lots of people
who don't like Russia and have ample
reason to do this aside from the U.S
I can't that was the first thing I
thought was like I think Russia's gonna
suffer in Germany's gonna suffer but the
the leak is in Western territory much
harder for Russia to get to if Russia
was going to sabotage you they could do
it closer to their territory where it's
safer
how much environmental damage is this
doing we have natural gas it's not I
don't think it's that big not really
okay it's not like a whale or anything
it's just in a leaf mayor Mercury says
it's the first time in two weeks I was
notified of the stream going live also I
have been subbed for the last three
years yet YouTube says I can't chat
because I'm not subbed only Super Chat
sup Luke
they're giving us the business they're
giving us the business it's funny that
all of us you know there was a period
where you couldn't Google search any of
the clips from this channel
funny and then we complained that on the
show one day and then the next day you
could search for him again magical yeah
yup they're playing dirty games
let's see what we got here
Reginald fluffington says I would love
to see upper echelon on Sunday he is
well spoken and researches his content
meticulously is he a try guy I don't
know I don't know who he is
viperman says as president Trump always
says Tim cast IRL is the best it really
is the best you should all tune in he
does say that it's the greatest show in
the country
you know somebody says country he goes
like a down tone countries greatest show
in the country
in the country it's the greatest show at
least that's what I was told yes
you know who does a great Trump by the
way uh Shane Gillis you haven't had in
mind oh yeah he does he does a great
Trump he is a great Trump
JJ says I can't believe a sitting U.S
president has not reached out to the
governor and the people to offer the
full support to the government what kind
of USA do we let them create uh there's
a civil war going on in case you haven't
noticed yeah Biden called all the Mayors
but he wouldn't call DeSantis no no I I
think the uh the head of FEMA uh
Criswell I think she spoke to him and uh
because Biden doesn't want to speak if I
just want to say and DeSantis doesn't
want to speak to Biden this is a good
one uh Heather V says who knew the
October surprise would be world war
three right
we talked about this yeah we talked
about this you said Joe Biden might
actually start a conflict because it
would improve his his ratings and give
them a distraction and rally people
wartime presidency their approval
ratings go up look when Donald Trump
bombs Syria the media was like he's
truly presidential now you remember that
they were like is this Trump being a
true president because he bombed Syria
over a rumor yeah
bad Trump
all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says guys
I want to thank you all for the master
class on investigative journalism last
night on uncensored now I know how to
find them big old Luke milkers damn
right lukemilkers.com is this going to
be the all week is this a thing or uh
what what thing what are you talking you
on your phone during Super Chat yes I'm
reading the chat I read the chat more
than anybody else and I don't know what
you're alluding to this is my natural
beautiful body that's right did you dye
your hair red no just got a little Sun a
little so this is good Nate Parrott says
second day in a row I actually got a
notification for the show weird after so
long of having to look up the show
specifically and we can see it like this
is a crazy thing so we we have an
average we know the average viewer right
you can look up on various website
showing you the average live viewers and
when people were saying they weren't
getting notified we can see that the
average live viewer was going down
and it was like okay they're clearly
suppressing the show now it's gone up
and people are like I'm getting
notifications again as of yesterday it's
funny how that works yeah Luke mentioned
this what happened last week that they
shut off notifications for us we started
talking about it oh shut it off I don't
know well Luke was saying that you get
three notifications a day per Channel we
have been doing the same clips and
everything our Clips are still getting
mad traffic we're still doing we produce
I think around six clips per day and we
we do four for the next day which are
news and then two which are more
Evergreen we say for the weekends that's
how we end up with multiple well maybe
it's the new shorts are have been
interfering with more people we're still
doing more vocal we're still yeah maybe
maybe the admins have put the live show
on priority number one list so you're
always going to get a notification for
the live show but not last week just
this one week after we started talking
about it maybe I don't know yeah maybe
kid truck says you guys should get
Brandon Herrera the AKA guy in sometimes
absolutely we've been trying yeah last
year we were like we gotta have him on
uh and then he was like yes and now I
think he might be busy with something I
don't know but but if you're listening I
think he would be great maybe come out
on a Friday so we could actually do some
like shooting and some like Vlog stuff
on the weekend which would be really
cool if we were gonna get him Lydia
would have gotten him already like she's
she's some people are hit up and they're
too good for no I'm just kidding too
good for us he's super super busy and I
know he's constantly creating videos so
I understand I'll text him again I think
this will be my third time hopefully
that's charm sleep is the cousin of
death says we know absolutely nothing
about what happened
reported leak you call explosion then
blame America WTF kinda garbage
reporting is this well good sir if you
watch the video then you will know it is
that there are researchers in Sweden and
Denmark seismologists who reported two
separate distinct explosions followed by
a stream vibration showing that it very
much uh tracks alongside an explosion
and then a gas leak which is what two
independent research organizations said
and we have a video of Joe Biden saying
he was going to end the Nordstrom
pipeline there wouldn't be one so it's
kind of like put two and two together
well I'm not saying we know for sure but
I'm saying hey if the U.S is conducting
Naval operations near born home Denmark
and then a few months later there's a
there's two explosions and then a major
gas leak after Joe Biden said he was
going to end the nordstream pipeline I
have to wonder what happened
okay I mean it's it's just a lot of
assumptions and conjecture and
you know we'll we'll know we'll know
more we'll know more but but you know I
I kind of get what he's saying keep an
open mind and don't believe anything
that anyone tells you at first be
skeptic all right don't tread on me says
keto Works my husband lost 60 pounds and
I've lost 20. why the food pyramid watch
Fed Up documentary very interesting
information about the sugar industry I
think it's high fructose corn syrup dude
yes fed up I think I'd second that watch
Fed Up it's a Katie Couric documentary
about the sugar industry and it's
Insidious it was like you lost me okay I
think it's high for sure I think it's a
huge but it's been since 1992. and you
can see the scale of obesity since then
I think it's high fructose corn syrup
and it's something specific to high
fructose corn syrup because I cut out
sugar and I started losing a lot of
weight really quickly relatively quickly
and then I was like oh it's because it's
keto it's right you know it's it's you
know high fat low carb you know high
protein all that stuff or not too high
of protein because gluconeogenesis but
anyway digress and then uh in the past
couple of weeks I introduced some sugars
back into the diet but I've only been
doing like healthier sugars I haven't
been doing yeah
so like I got ketchup but it's like no
sugar added ketchup so the carbs that
are international that's like the
organic the organic ketchup yeah and
pineapple the pineapple juice I would
drink periodically and that's like 30
carbs and I was still losing weight I'm
still going down I feel natural it's
natural I think it's something with high
fructose corn syrup because what we've
been talking about is
we've all experienced this as we've
talked about it more and more people we
know who would eat the same food in a
foreign country come here eating the
same food gained massive weight then go
back to their home country and the
weight disappears even though their
eating habits don't change I had a
chemical engineer that works in the
sweetener industry contact me at least
this is who they were claiming to be and
said that there's no arsenic used in the
production I had claimed that I'd read I
thought I'd read that they washed the
tanks with arsenic between production of
high fructose but he said that there's
acrylic resin used I don't can't confirm
or deny it but if they sent me a patent
patents uh
us-4523960 a you could rewind the show
and watch that again if you want that
patent all right Eric K says the
pipeline going down is not in Biden's
interest as it will create pressure to
increase domestic production of fuel
Ukraine is the culprit Imo that's
interesting but but Biden also said that
there were going to be food shortages
there was going to be there was going to
be pain and you know why should you know
if if it's to his
you know if if it's to his agenda then
why why shouldn't he let Europe suffer
you know I mean it'll just push them to
do green energy quicker the Magic Bullet
of uh you know windmills and all that
stuff Pittsburgh says they announced
Deadpool 3 and now Biden is going to
start world war three way to ruin
everyone's fun Brandon not only that but
Hugh Jackman's gonna be in it yes maybe
it'll be a cameo we'll see
apparently he's gonna be Wolverine and
that's really really cool I I hope I
hope it's full-fledged main character
next to Deadpool that'd be amazing
probably Perez says pay attention to
Brazilian general elections this Sunday
if the left wins they will for sure cut
food production in the name of climate
change the world needs Brazilian food
production they will
I I think they will Bremen says Luke do
you have an only fans page I do it's
called lukemilkers.com and you can see
what I have going on my uncensored show
lukemilkers.com actual website amazing
if you did nude photos you'd make so
much money
that that's a sexist remark there Ian oh
sorry
to insinuate here just objective John
Francis says Crossland is a gift from
God don't lose hope even if you lose
energy keep grinding and don't stop
being you PS world-class fleece thank
you sir poor man
cap says Luke could sell more shirts if
they weren't all long sleeve you will
owe nothing and you will know nothing
will turn into the U1 Bill initiative
mark my words probably but uh it's not
just long sleeves they're short sleeves
there's women shirts uh we just did a
whole redesign of
thebestpoliticalshirts.com and you could
actually look at uh sweaters you could
look at any type of shirts that you want
I was just joking about these photos too
I mean you would make money but I don't
want to encourage you to do anything
like that Rob says Tim I love your show
but I have to say you lived in Jersey
not Philly I'm a Philly native suburbs
of Philly means Delaware County not
kanchi not Jersey also Ian Gets a bad
rap love you dude yeah look first for
people who live in Philly they probably
have their colloquial terms but speaking
generally to everyone on the planet
explaining that I live
three miles away from Philly like I
gotta say I live in the suburbs of
Philly because I don't want to say I
lived in Philly but how else do you
describe it do I get into the do I just
go well I didn't live in the suburbs
because people there don't actually
think Jersey of that way and it was only
about three miles away but you know it's
there you go that's like saying that you
lived in the city when you actually
lived in Queens yeah you know in Chicago
some of the suburbs of Chicago were like
60 miles away and people like where you
live like Chicago and then you ask them
what part and they'll be like Saint
Charles or Geneva and you're like dude
that's like 60 miles out of the city but
but in Chicago it's a suburb it's a
suburb even though it's like more than
an hour drive away but I love I love
this whenever I meet a person and
they'll go I'll say where are you from
they'll go Chicago I'll go oh me too and
they'll go which part I'll be back
Midway and I'm like and you're from
Naperville and they go how did you know
because it always like I'm telling you
this there is if you're gonna make a bet
it's that people who have lived in
Chicago in the Chicagoland area and then
moved there's a high likelihood they
were from Naperville I got a lot of good
friends from Naperville yeah in downtown
something about Naperville make people
want to flee the Chicagoland area I
don't know what it is speaking of
Philadelphia I hear that the
Philadelphia Eagles are better
than the Eagles I I heard that I heard
that from a guy yeah
Amanda Del says Luke you're wrong I
worked at Wawa in Clearwater Florida and
concealed carry while at work
yeah but you you need uh I think you
need to like it yeah uh special permit
in Florida
yeah did you guys see Jupiter no I'll
look after this
show how many nights has it been out I
saw a super bright star it's supposed to
be super big super big like like what's
under Luke's shirt super big
sorry I'm not I'm not trying to uh yeah
I don't want to be that guy P2 hang says
pigs can be 500 pounds so can the New
Yorkers hmm
oh Joshua Runner there's your loophole
Coley and Noir just did a video on a
bunch of M16s found in Old Surplus
crates you see this story no some people
bought crates from a surplus store
opened it up and found a whole bunch of
M16s those got to be like what 10K each
well depends if there's uh you know full
auto I have 16s they're select fire so
what's likely gonna the government's
gonna seize them I have to imagine
they're like you can't have those if you
found a bunch of cash would be like hey
yeah yup it's ours now
wait was he was he there actually
they're looking at the he did a video
about them or like it's a news story oh
okay I thought he was all right I was
like oh he he was actually there looking
at the crates that would have been cool
all right DJ Madero says this is the
anniversary of the movie Soylent Green
the movie takes place in the year 2022
and some of the similarities with today
are are scary also it was Edward G
Robinson last movie he filmed his death
scene in the movie the same day that he
died yeah
and now they're saying they can compost
people into soil oh yeah you see that
one in California yes apparently it's
already legal it's legal now or oh oh it
was legal in other states before
California and California they weren't
first adopters but those other states
have restrictions like you can't use the
soil for food
what yeah but California I guess doesn't
have that
so that's crazy they're just a very
Progressive state
somebody's got to take the first step
yeah
all right let's carry on with the show
David C Cronk senior says poor canado
the pigs cometh too
yeah working NATO
hmm oh man what is this one MB says
Chinese Russian warship formation off
Alaska Coast per the Coast Guard we I
saw that world war three baby I hope you
guys have supplies cause uh
oh dark days indeed World War III is
really great for the great reset though
because if they want there to be less
people and they want people to use less
resources like a third world war that
wipes out substantial portions of the
world population would be like perfectly
in line with you know population
reduction that's one way to do it
certainly
there's a conspiracy theory that the
wars are only for culling populations
hmm there's a lot of conspiracy theories
for a lot of things but I was reading
sure cookie what you know stuff on the
internet and they were talking about how
the reason for the wars is to stimulate
the economy because the economy is fake
and then to also call the human
population and I'm like
that's stupid because there are actual
reasons behind War like we want oil or
territory so why would it just be random
World War one I don't I still don't know
why they were fighting why they kept it
up for so long for five years of trench
warfare where they'd take two miles or a
half a mile and then take it back and
then take it back and death you were
right
rocket saw says it was Simpson's
Halloween episode Lisa wishes for world
peace all weapons disappeared the aliens
showed up and Enslaved the world ah the
episode ends with a character chasing
the aliens with a board with a nail in
it I remember that he's got a boat with
a nail in it run see I you know with a
nail in it I don't I don't I I watch
Family Guy occasionally but you know I
kind of felt like it was a Simpson so
thank you very much for uh proving me
right
Martin Edgar says you have no idea how
vicious and tough feral pigs are a
perfect heart shot won't stop them so a
knife tied to a stick will mostly just
piss it off some people have pointed out
in like in Australia they go with dogs
and knives to hunt the pigs and I'm like
I hear you man but like a like trained
Hunters who know how to go after pigs
and are doing it intentionally with
knives I get you think like a regular
New Yorker is going to go up against a
feral hog with a knife now you give you
give a random New Yorker an AR-15 with
30 rounds and they're still going to
have a hard time dealing with the hog
but they will deal with the hog you know
you give someone trained with an AR they
could probably take the dog out the hog
out the hog out in a couple shots
probably someone was trained a single
shot you know to the head or something
but the average person with a rifle is
going to be able to stop the hog albeit
not as well as someone who's trained you
should watch videos of feral Hogs moving
around because they're fast and agile do
you guys see that that story about the
woman who killed the dog and thought it
was a wolf yeah oh yeah
she killed a Siberian Husky and there's
like I got a wolf puppy like yo that's a
dog you killed a dog skinned it in a pot
posted the photos are gruesome and the
heart don't look out oh no don't do that
yeah and they were like defending it but
acknowledging they did something wrong
but like
horrible horrible I'm sure they're going
through their own trauma after they
realized it was a husky yeah well
apparently they were abandoned and so
they were kind of they were feral like
someone dropped a bunch of huskies and
then they grew up and were just pet yeah
I wasn't like a person owned the dog can
you imagine like a a rabid mean husky
like like a husky pup like I don't know
Sumner Robertson says Tim you need to
look into the dollar milkshake Theory by
Brent Johnson explains what's going
going to come over the next few years
well okay
someone can look at that I guess
Devlin Foster says to further debunk
bilbur's narrative Rand Paul was
attacked and severely beaten by his
neighbor good point and Scott Adams
Scott Adams and Bill Burr both said to
in various ways there won't be civil war
because neighbors aren't fighting each
other
and the point I made was like
a dude in Atlanta in 1861 didn't walk
out of his house and go oh I'm just so
mad at those Northerners I'm gonna go
punch my neighbor like why would people
who agree with each other and live in
the same place be fighting like the
Civil Wars when different groups of
people who hate each other come and
fight so but in this point it is a good
point Rand Paul's neighbor attacked him
and he lost a piece of lung or something
over it was crazy
so yeah what was the reason
um I don't know I don't think it was
political to be honest okay immediate
casualty care says Bill Burns got Adam
saying there's no Civil War coming
because I looked outside and no one is
fighting as a bold statement for people
who mock those who say global warming
isn't real because it's snowing now
yeah it's it's uh it's snowing because
of global warming dummies
you should cast a spell to end the
hurricane and then roll that D20 right
there to see if it succeeds
no that's right it's a great one the
gray one that one okay yeah all right
Ian's going to roll for initiative he's
attempting to dispel hurricane Ian
Ian roll the 20. oh look at that I wrote
a 20 on a 20-sided die of all 20s but
that was just I'm Gonna Roll an actual
20-sided die see if it actually works
yeah I think the Hurricane's here to
stand someone or David Ray on the
comment section said it'll be a one or
the legit a one yeah
no no no no no the one means that it's
gonna be weak
he legit rolled away it wasn't just I
critically failed I might have actually
no it was a hurricane no it wasn't the
spell you were you were rolling to uh
show the strength you left you escaped
from Florida yeah okay yeah okay first
of all yes I am a refugee now from
Florida uh yeah we can't send them back
but I you know I I had planned this and
you brought your suitcase here okay
you're not you're not going okay back
first of all I planned this in advance
before there was Hurricane Ian or
whatever right then I packed a suitcase
because I thought that there was the
potential for my flight to be canceled
going back which would have been
tomorrow morning and in fact it was
canceled because uh Orlando shut down
the whole airport okay so it's a real uh
yeah yeah yeah from 10 a.m tomorrow
for people who don't understand the
reference in Dungeons and Dragons if you
take an action and roll a 20 it's a
critical success and like good things
happen if you're one it's a critical
failure and extremely bad things happen
I was trying to spin it the gag I was
saying is that we have a 20-sided die
that's all 20s can't fail so it's saying
Ian try and dispel the hurricane and
roll that guarantees so it's kind of a
joke
but then Ian actually rolls a D20 and
got a one yeah and it's just like okay
there are no coincidence add them both
together it's 21. there you go all right
Peter Gerrard says Andrew your videos
were a huge influence on changing my
views and how I now analyze politics
first time I ever watched IRL was when
you were on Now I watch every one of
Tim's four daily videos four
keep doing God's work guys it makes a
difference oh well you're welcome Tim
for getting you a very loyal listen uh
viewer you're you're welcome and I thank
you thank you seven videos per day
actually I think we do four IRL clips
and then I do three uh monologue videos
and uh well I mean it depends how deep
you go into the timcast network but uh
pop culture crisis has I think three
Clips a day and the live show
lots of machine here guys Tim I think
the try guys do one where they go to a
gun range if you want to cringe watch
that one I don't know if I'd cringe like
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna mock someone
who's not familiar with guns going and
trying guns you know what I mean right
unless they end by saying all guns are
bad and we proved it but if it's just
like some like Low T guys being like
we'll try guns I'm like that's really
cool you guys thank you for for you know
trying that out the try guys shoot each
other
yeah no like I wanna I wanna be clear
like I don't mean a rag on those guys I
got no beef you know good on them for
having their show yeah sure and it's you
know people like it I'm not trying to
just hate on for for no reason the Low T
thing but the guy cheated on his wife
he's bad that is bad but like the low T
thing is no it's like I'm not trying to
rag on them when I bring that up to
point out what's happening to this
generation is serious guys gotta
exercise more am I I got look my resting
heart rate this is kind of scared the
crap out of me is 42.
so like I've been I've been exercising I
skate all the time and then in the past
recently it's like my heart rate got way
down because it was like high 40s before
now it's even lower dude I was soaking
in the tub uh four or five days ago and
I went underwater submerged and I was
just thinking about gaming with Trent
pixelated Apollo what's up dog and about
how good it was and I was just
visualizing the game and then like a
minute went by and I realized I was
still underwater like my body was not
using oxygen or I was pulling the oxygen
out of the water or something Ian we
also could have worked out today and you
could have been stacked like I am and uh
once again once again you didn't come
out yeah last Friday it didn't happen
I said Tuesday we're doing two things I
had the personal trainer come out and
use an extra classes he's an awesome
trainer yeah I mean you clearly see I
mean my body has it going on all right
everybody if you haven't already but you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the share with
your friends become a member at
timcast.com to watch the uncensored
members only show coming up at 11 PM you
can follow the show at timcast IRL
basically everywhere you can follow me
at timcast don't walk run Productions
now what I know uh
you can follow me on Twitter at don't
walk run all one word uh you can follow
me on Instagram at don't walk run
Productions and of course check out my
channel on YouTube don't lock Run
Productions and um
yeah I post I post a lot on Twitter and
I get a I get you know I'm kind of a
jerk on Twitter like you know I'll I'll
go to politicians and who say oh haters
there's voter suppression I'll go show
me evidence of voter suppression and I
will delete my account you know and then
and they never they they can never ever
say uh you know like I know what I'm
talking about anyway follow me on
Twitter follow me on YouTube uh
and how about you uh young uh lady woman
man what what is what is happening here
Luke milkers.com is the website that
everyone needs to go to right now and I
wanna I wanna thank everyone for uh
pumping me up in the chat room Tim stop
it
um I want to thank everyone calling me
beautiful and brave stunning and brave I
want to shout out specifically the
person that said Luke Rakowski and I
want to shout out the person that said
Luke the the uniboobber and Libby Evans
Nancy Pelosi I am I'm giving them a run
for their money watch out
lukemilkers.com see you there
all right geez that's fantastic dude I
just want to follow I just want to poke
it with my with my aquamarine do you
understand it's cut we don't need it we
don't need a mic stand anymore this
thing just stands right there you guys
follow me at Ian Crossland anywhere on
the internet until next time
see you later
I think I can get it what are you doing
over there
anyway I'm also here being upstaged by
my questionably male co-host this
evening I won't judge no worries he's
not judging this is this you're doing
awesome
I'm just moving around geez guys
you guys gawking at me all the time it's
true it's rampant sexism over here uh
we're gonna go to the after show where
we can be more sexist to my co-host here
you guys can follow me on
twitterminds.com
Luna Wayman power okay that's true yeah
I I'm in huge solidarity here you can
also find me at sourpetlands.me and
Timothy I'm trying to share this video
on Instagram but it's not letting me
know
uh wow
you've never been sexier I'll figure it
out I'll figure it out all right
everybody we'll see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out